Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim. Ja, ich weiß nicht, dass ich kommen werde. Oskar ähm des Politikers. Lalaland.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertzwölf rauscht äh heran, etwas vorzeitig, denn wir haben uns heute äh was ausgedacht. Wir wollen äh heute die Oscars äh in der Netzpolitik vergeben, weil aller Land war's dann doch nicht.
Die Oscars in, nee, es war Mondlicht natürlich Spione treffen sich bei Mondlich,
und nicht im Lagerland. Das ist noch ganz klar.
Ja genau und äh um den äh äh ja um irgendwo eine eine nachvollziehbare Entscheidung herbeizuführen, haben wir auch eine Jury berufen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von den Oscars. Ich habe seit gestern mein Internet noch nicht aufgemacht.
Desaster. Fake Oscars.
Genau,
in Form von Andre Meister, hallo Andre, willkommen bei Netzpolitik.
Äh bevor wir das waren, wollte ich aber noch ganz kurz äh das,
zur letzten Sendung anschauen,
ein Spiel. Nee, weil der Ball äh war eine wichtige Sache drin und das äh fand ich ganz interessant. Zwar kommentiert ähm Eduard Leichenschläger,
äh kommentiert. Ähm die Herausgabe von äh Flüchtlingshandys,
nicht freiwillig geplant, wie hier behauptet, das soll verpflichtend werden. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das wirklich behauptet habe, aber,
auf jeden Fall. Recht. Und das Schöne ist, ähm warum wie kommt diese Fake News, die hier angeprangert wird zustande,
Da kann man nämlich so richtig schön wieder sehen
wie Gesetzesentwürfe funktionieren, ne? Im äh Gesetzesentwurf steht äh Paragraph fünfzehn wird wie folgt geändert, äh Absatz zwei Nummer sechs wird wie folgt gefasst
Punkt Punkt Punkt auch verlangen, alle Datenträger, die für die Feststellung seiner Identität und Staatsangehörigkeit von Bedeutung sein können und in deren Besitz er ist.
Und da es ja semantisch noch nicht so hundert Prozent klar, dass äh dass man verpflichtet ist. Das geht aber erst. Das näm,
nämlich erst daraus hervor, wenn man sich diesen Paragraphen fünfzehn Absatz zwei Asylgesetz in seiner,
Aktuell gültigen Formen anschaut, da ist nämlich der einleitende Satz,
ist insbesondere verpflichtet, ähm, der jetzt quasi in dem neuen Gesetzesentwurf,
Steht das Wort verpflichtet, nicht wirklich drin, aber aus dem DIV ergibt es sich halt, ne?
Mhm.
So wie man auch so 'ne Backdoor in so einem Comit unterbringt ist hier der ergibt sich dann der Satz verpflichtet. Weiter ist auch noch schön dieser Satz der im Gesetzesentwurf steht in Absatz
In Absatz vier Satz eins werden nach dem Wort nachkommt die Wörter sowie nicht gemäß Absatz zwei Nummer sechs auf Verlangen die Datenträger vorliegt aushändigt oder überlässt. Und
werden nach dem Wort Unterlagen, die Wörter oder Datenträger einge,
ja klar was damit gemeint ist, ne? Ähm.
Der der im momentan geltenden Gesetz beginnt dieser Satz mit die mit der Ausführung dieses Gesetzes betrauten Behörden können den Ausländer und Sachen, die von ihm mitgeführt werden durchsuchen. Äh und dieser Satz wird also dann quasi geändert, ne? Das heißt,
die können im Prinzip alles was er hat durchsuchen und natürlich auch seine.
Ähm anderer Kommentar sagte, äh wir hätten erwähnen müssen, dass das momentan noch nicht geht,
Wer der noch nicht legal ist, na ja äh Gesetze sind immer dafür da, etwas äh momentan nicht Legales,
äh legal zu machen oder etwas momentan,
erlaubt es zu verbieten, insofern äh denke ich, das hätte sich aus,
Kontext äh durchaus ergeben können. Aber ja, verpflichtend, wir reden hier nicht von freiwillig. Ich habe das Pferd ja versucht von dieser, ne? Es hat ja auch was für sich.
Ähm Seite aufzuziehen, ähm das musst du mal äh hier nochmal äh konkretisiert werden. Dann haben wir ähm.
Ein äh Kommentar zu zu Spam-Kontrolle. Wir hatten ja über darüber gesprochen, wie wie wir,
Links klicken oder nicht. Natürlich nicht.
Mhm. Natürlich nicht.
Wir haben das aber auch da irgendwie an das äh festgestellt. Ähm.
Aber äh da hier gefragt wurde, ich bin ja mal gespannt wie Linus äh Spam-Kontrolle vornimmt. Kann ich ganz einfach erklären. Ich benutze für die Anmeldung bei irgendwelchen für das Angeben von E-Mail-Adressen irgendwo.
Eine Domän, äh die ein Catch-All-E-Mail-Server hat,
heißt jeder jeder der meine E-Mail-Adresse haben möchte für seinen komischen Dienst kriegt von mir eine andere Adresse.
Was den wunderschönen Vorteil hat, der sich sofort sehe, wer die geliebt hat,
Also wer ähm welcher Dienst gerade wieder aufgemacht wurde und die E-Mail-Adressen im Spampool gelandet sind.
Beziehungsweise für den nicht vereinbarten Zweck verwendet hat.
Ja, also bei häufig, wenn die.
Newsletter und so.
Oder genau für den nicht vereinbarten Zweck verwendet hat. Also man kann das sofort sehen,
den weiteren Vorteil hat, also kommt natürlich einfach erstmal in den Inbox an, aber wenn ich sehe, dass da irgendwie
dass diese E-Mail-Adresse jetzt auf irgend so einer Spam-Liste ist, dann äh wird einfach unter dem Namen,
Postfach eröffnet, was alles nach DF null wirft und dann äh landet's nicht mehr.
Das wäre auch mal eine schöne Funktion für so äh Standard-E-Mail-Anbieter, dass ihr so quasi solche Varianten der eigenen Geschädigte, also man kann ja so bei.
Machen sie.
Bei manchen kann man zumindest so, dass es automatisch in so einem Folder landet, aber das ist vielleicht auch ein anderes Verhalten äh anzeigt äh aufweist.
Bei Google kannst du glaube ich irgendwas mit Plus machen.
Genau, damit hast du eine das quasi in so ein Folie einsortiert, aber du hast halt nicht gleich,
ein anderes Verhalten. Na ja egal.
Ja, aber so mache ich das und äh die Abmeldenlinks schaue ich mir mitunter, einfach natürlich mal den Link an,
der einfach nur Subscribe PAP äh Anzugscryp, PRP heißt oder ob dahinter irgendwie ein riesen langer,
Trackingpixel ist äh äh ein Tracking-Code ist. Ähm das kann man sich ja dann irgendwie nochmal,
ähm anschauen. Übrigens dieses Rumspielding hier ist gefährlich, ne? Das kommt mal.
Ja, ja, das kommt mal weg.
Nicht, dass du hier rumspielst.
Äh dann haben wir noch äh ein ein, also auch da da fasst man sich ja wirklich an den Kopf.
Jetzt schickt uns jemand über Twitter ein ähm einen Ausschnitt aus der aktuellen Zeit,
Und da steht drin in Deutschland viel im November bei neunhunderttausend Kunden der Telekom das Internet aus
Eindringlinge hatten versucht ein neues Botnetz aufzubauen. Aber dann schalteten sich die angegriffenen WLAN-Router der Kunden automatisch ab, bevor sie gekapert werden konnten, eine Art Selbstschutz
der Geräte. Das ist.
Sowas von falsch, das ist sowas von unsinnig und ich kann mir das kaum noch mit ähm,
Also es ist katastrophal, dass irgendwie, also das da muss man wirklich überhaupt nicht,
gelesen haben, was da passiert ist oder bösartig,
kut willig,
für die Telekom hier berichten wollen, um so einen Unsinn zu behaupten. Die Dinger hatten eine Wein-Rebility und sind abgeschmiert,
wenn ein Gerät auf einmal kaputt ist,
nicht mehr funktioniert, dann ist auch das ein Schaden. Wenn auch, wenn gleich auch dieser Schaden nicht von,
Angreifern beabsichtigt war. Ähm ich habe das aber ausführlich in der Folge Unglück im Glück, im Unglück,
LNP habe ich nicht, weiß ich nicht. Rund zweihundert noch was, erklärt. Hier das prangern wir an,
aber in der Zeit äh steht ja öfter mal.
So ist das jetzt ausführen, was die Zeit geschrieben hat? Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Wollen wir das überhaupt kommentieren.
Äh. Fake News, ne? Ist Fake News, fak.
Ne? Das ist einfach nur Fake New.
Wir sind Schuld an Fake News, Wahlmanipulationen und Massenunruhen durch Fake News.
Massenunruhen durch Fake News gesehen? Das steht in der gedruckten Papierzeitung.
Also Netzpolitik Ork äh ist natürlich, das geht so nicht, ne? Also ist irgendwie so rücksichtsloser äh investigativer Journalismus, ohne vorher mal nach der bei der Zeit anzuklopfen und zu fragen, wie die das wollen, das geht nicht.
Na ja, aber das ist irgendwie, die schreiben halt auch auf Papier. Die haben wir ganz andere Sorgen noch, ne?
Das war so ein Dreiseiten äh.
Weiß ich nicht, wie man das nennen soll. Stück äh von der stellvertretenden Chefredakteurin über die Affäre Landesverrat und warum
Justizminister Maaß mit der war's eine Weisung oder nicht, hat den Generalbundesanwalt die Ermittlungen gegen uns ein,
wie er sich da in die Nesseln gesetzt hat, aber die Redakteurin macht keinen Hill daraus
äh durchblicken zu lassen auf Wesse, welcher Seite sie steht und dass wir die böse sind und fälligst verurteilt gehören.
So geil. Das ist echt so.
Aber ist noch nicht online erschienen. Ich weiß nicht warum. Ja. Trauen sich nicht.
Haben sie bestimmt Angst, dass sie sich damit einen Dedos einhandeln äh wie methodisch inkorrekt vor ein paar Tagen,
Ähm vielleicht sollten wir das kurz erklären. Wir hatten ja in wir wurden ja letzte Sendungen überfallen von Doktor Duss.
Herr Doktor, das ist ein eine indische Koryphäe der Gebetswissenschaft. Äh die regelmäßig in dem Podcast methodisch inkorrekt zu.
Forum findet.
Ein Forum findet aber auch doch äh zutiefst diskreditiert wird, ne? Also so ohne ohne weitere Prüfung werden da die die wird ja die Forschung diskreditiert. Hm, die dieser Mann zum zum All-might.
Leistet, ja, ja, also.
Das wird also der Witter regelmäßig verunglimpft und äh hat hier Rache genommen für das äh methodisch inkorrekt
Intro, in dem aufgefordert wurde, die Seite Logbuchnetzpolitik zu mit einer Cyberattacke zu überziehen
Doktor Das hatte die Seite Lockbruchnetzpolitik dann gekauft. Ähm.
Wohlgemerkt, nicht Lockbuch Bindestrich Netzpolitik Punkt DE.
Und da darauf hingewiesen, dass man, dass die Cyberattacke bitte da lang gehen sollte.
Und für einen kurzen Moment ist, sie ist dann auch, also es gab da so ein kurz kurzzeitigen Ausfall der Seite äh von methodisch inkorrekt. Das prangern wir an.
Jetzt prangern wir an. Sowas äh.
Ja wir verurteilen das und weisen solche Verhalten weit von uns und das war auch nicht beabsichtigt und.
War nicht beabsichtigt, aber ich meine, wenn man wenn man sich als wehrloser Physiker mit ein paar Hackern anlegt, kann man sich halt auch überlegen, was dabei rumkommt, wenn man jetzt ausgerechnet Cyberattacken fordert, ne? Also war jetzt auch irgendwie abzusehen.
Das kann äh rückfeuern.
Ne? Finde ich so andere Podcasts, die die sagen dann immer so, gibt uns Sterne bei iTunes, ähm äh empfehlt uns in den sozialen Medien,
Engagement ist einfach nur so was.
Genau.
So machen wir das halt. Genau. So, dann haben wir ähm alles durch, ne? Die wurde eine Puppe noch verboten, das das fand ich eigentlich nur witzig.
Die Puppe keiner wurde verboten, die muss jetzt vernichtet werden. Die ist eine äh illegale Abhör ähm,
illegale Abhörpuppe, äh die hat die Bundesnetzagentur jetzt verboten und wer die besitzt, muss sie zerstören, fand ich lustig.
Ja, Popokai da, sorry, aber einfach nur so Kinder äh abhorchen und ab,
ich meine es ist ja jetzt irgendwie gerade so ein so ein neuer Trendsichtgeräte ins Haus zu stellen,
die einfach mal so bei Defold alles äh,
Ja, allem zuhören und zwar nicht nur also nicht nur aufzeichnen, sondern die auch fortwährend interpretieren, was man so sagt.
Alles schon echt skerry. Also äh das.
Also ich bin, ich bin ja ich bin ja sehr offen für moderne technische Entwicklungen und ich probiere auch vieles aus, aber da ist einfach mal schon vorher schon Schluss.
Also kriegen deine Kinder nicht. Gut.
Nicht von Apple.
Das Ding ist aber natürlich in dem Moment, wo so ein Ding verboten wird, explodiert natürlich der Schwarzmarkt, ne? Bei eBay, wer eBay kommt mit dem Löschen nicht nach. Wenn die Leute versuchen, die illegale Puppe zu verschicken.
Ich hätte gerne eine. Also sowieso äh anonyme Zuschriften.
Sind immer wieder gerne gesehen, das sollte ich an dieser Stelle eh nochmal ganz kurz äh prinzipiell indiferentlobend erwähnen, so diese ähm die anonymen Zuschriften sind immer gut und helfen uns auch, selbst wenn wir das hier,
nicht erwähnen. Ich kriegte, ich mache nämlich dem Andre jetzt Konkurrenz, ich kriege nämlich jetzt auch Leaks.
Elekt.
Puppen liegst.
Naja, jeder halt in sein. So, damit.
Eigentlich äh wollten wir uns ja über,
was Ernsthaftes unterhalten, genau und wie nun schon äh zuletz,
vermeldet und sicherlich auch euch allen schon berei,
ist ja jetzt der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss nach vielen Jahren des Betriebs,
zu Ende gegangen. Die letzte Sitzung hat stattgefunden, nochmal unter grandioser Beteiligung von unserer Bundeskanzlerin, die äh abschließend zur Aufklärung äh beigetragen hat. Habe ich gehört.
Andre. Dein Name ist äh mit diesem Untersuchungsausschuss äh fest vertackert. Da kannst du nicht mehr raus aus der Nummer.
Du und natürlich auch äh das ganze Team von Netzpolitik Org hat sich äh nachhaltig bemüht hier ähm den Schriftführer zu spielen.
Jetzt ja leider auch offiziell gab, aber der das abgetippte leider nicht verbreiten durfte, deswegen ist ja,
quasi euer Narrativ auch so ein bisschen, dass äh das definierende Moment so für die Geschichtsschreibung.
Man hörte ja dann auch immer wieder, dass auch so andere Stellen sich äh äh dort informiert haben, weil andere Quellen es ja nicht gab.
Schon mal auch ein kleiner Erfolg, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, wenn der Ausschuss gewusst hätte, äh dass das so eine Ausmaße ausnimmt, dann hätten sie die Protokolle lieber gleich veröffentlicht. Ähm,
Endeffekt haben wir den ja jetzt mehr Aufmerksamkeit geschafft, also vor, also äh,
wenn sie die Protokolle einfach als PDF ins Netz gedammt hätten, das hätte keine Sau interessiert.
Ja, das ist ja der der einzige Grund, warum es keine öffentlichen Streams und keine offiziellen Protokolle unmittelbar nach den Anhörungen gibt, ist,
Die anderen Zeugen könnten sich ja dann damit informieren und in der Strafprozessordnung geht das nicht und sowas wie Internet ist halt undenkbar. Früher durfte man halt,
Gerichtssaal zeichnen und eine zusammenfassende Zeitungsberichterstattung machen,
Aber dass dann jetzt irgendjemand hinkommt und tatsächlich möglichst Wort für Wort Detailgetreu mitschreibt,
hätten die sich nicht denken lassen nach den ersten ein, zwei Mal, wo wir das gemacht haben, gab's dann intern noch Diskussionen, mit dürfen die das,
und es stand mal kurzzeitig im Raum, dass,
live Twittern und das live protokollieren zu verbieten,
Damit haben sich die Abgeordneten, die das wollten aber dann nicht durchgesetzt und im Endeffekt, wir haben es ja von vielen Zeugen gehört, von BND und auch Kanzlerins Minister Altmaier, äh die alle die Livebox lesen, weil sie die offiziellen Protokolle nicht haben. Insofern ist das eigentliche Argument äh,
hinfällig gewesen, aber wir haben natürlich ähm mitgesorgt, also,
tatsächlich irgendwie auch wenn die Klickzahlen für die Live-Blogs ähm,
nicht so grandios sind und wir haben halt einen Preis vom Bundestag, vom Medienpreis, äh, für das Live-Blog bekommen und da war glaube ich in der, ja, ähm, zweiter Platz, Medienpreis des Bundestages,
kurz nach Landesverrat und da war glaube ich in der Laudatio drin, auch wenn das nicht immer Vergnügungssteuerpflichtig ist.
Haben wir aber glaube ich für ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit für den äh Ausschuss gesorgt, als es sonst wäre, wenn's eben nur die zusammenfassenden Berichte bei.
Meistens heiße Golem.
Öfters mal Zeit und nur wenn's irgendwie einen Kracher oder einen hohen Zeugen gab, äh dann auch mal so einen Spiegelartikel oder einen zwanzig Sekunden Tagesschau, Clip äh gab.
Aber die haben sich dann alle in der letzten Sitzung bei Merkel wieder reingedrän,
und um ihre Plätze gekämpft äh aber wir,
gehören irgendwie so ein bisschen zum Inventar, haben wirklich jede Sitzung äh mitgenommen von den sechsundsechzig Stück.
Von den sechsundsechzig öffentlichen, ne?
Sechsundsechzig öffentliche,
Anhörungen von Zeugen und Sachverständigen und dann gibt's natürlich noch die internen Sitzungen des Ausschusses, wo die entscheiden, welche Zeugen sie anhören und wann, in welcher Reihenfolge, welche Themen sie,
äh behandeln, wo sich so ihre internen Treffen machen. Das sind auch Sitzungen des Ausschusses, aber,
dürfen wir nicht reden.
Ist immer schön, wenn man da, wenn diese Sitzung beginnt, dann kommt eröffnet Patrick Sensburg den
dass das Parkett und gibt dann so Öffentlichkeit ist hergestellt, ne? Tür war offen, man konnte rein, so ungefähr und ähm,
jetzt gibt's dann dann wird immer noch so diese, jetzt gibt's die Fotoapportunity, ne? Dann kann da jeder nochmal fotografiert werden, dann
Das sind dann auch die Bilder, die wir in Netzpolitik Org erscheinen, wo dann oben von der Besuchertribüne einmal das Handy rüber gehalten wurde. Und dann kommt aber auch die Ansage, so wer jetzt noch Video oder Tonaufnahmen macht,
drakonische Strafen angedroht, ne.
Ausschuss aus dem Ausschuss oder Hausverbot oder sogar strafrechtlichere Konsequenzen. Ich kann den die Eingangsstatements, Eingangsformalitäten langsam mitbieten.
Äh vorübergehende Erschießung angeordnet.
Ist auch passiert letztes Mal, hat eine nicht die vorübergehende Erschießung äh eine Kollegin, ich glaube von der, ich weiß gar nicht,
Kann Zeit gewesen sein oder so. Äh hat ein Bild von Fritschek,
während der Sitzung geschossen und getwittert und dann kam die Saalpolizei und dann gemeint löschen bitte.
Weil verboten. Wer aber die Auftakt.
Nur mal so als wenn du das gemacht hättest, ne, meinst du da, wäre anders verfahren worden.
Kommt drauf an wann? Jetzt mittlerweile weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, also am Anfang gab's ja
skurrile Story, dass ich deinen Kopf hinter mir hatte,
Sitzung oder so, das ging hat dann auch Wellen geschlagen, aber irgendwie gehören wir so zum Inventar von dem Ausschuss, also wir durften da drinnen essen und trinken, irgendwann gab's mal einen neuen Kopf, weil
Wechsel gab, der wusste das nicht, hat uns dann gesagt, wir dürfen nicht essen und trinken und ist so, ey, nee, geh mal runter, frag mal nach. Hat er das gemacht und dann hat er gemeint, sorry, geht klar
Ja, weil normalerweise ist das in den Ausschusssälen nicht erlaubt, aber wir sitzen da dann halt manchmal zwöl,
drin und das geht halt nicht, wenn man da nichts trinken äh darf
war so ein bisschen Ausnahmesituation, aber ich glaube, ich hätte mich auch nicht rausreden können, mit ich wusste nicht, dass man das äh keine Fotos machen und twittern darf, insofern weiß ich nicht, was die Konsequenz gewesen wäre, aber dadurch,
die ganze Zeit damit beschäftigt bin, so möglichst wortgetreu
alles mitzutippen, habe ich gar keine Zeit, ein Foto zu machen und das auch noch zu vertwittern.
Äh das ist wirklich eine also so viele Stunden hochkonzentriert das äh zu protokollieren ist wirklich irre
Also das ist die richtige Folter. Also wenn man dann irgendwie bei
bei technischer Aufklärung regelmäßig gehört hat, dass irgendwie du oder Anna nicht mehr mit Podcast, weil ihr einfach durch seid. Das kann man sich, denke ich, lebhaft vorstellen, wenn man euch da mal hat, sitzen sehen.
Die offiziellen Stellographen werden jede Stunde gewechselt, die haben eine Gewerkschaft, aber wir sitzen da manchmal zwölf Stunden,
mal fünf Minuten Pause dazwischen.
Ja Kinderarbeit ist das. Denkst du denn, dass das ähm möglicherweise eine langfristige Auswirkung hat,
Praxisprotokolle nicht zu veröffentlichen bei Ausschuss äh Sitzung, bei Untersuchungsausschüssen,
Kann sich das gibt's am Wandel.
Das will ich schlecht mutmaßen, weil wir haben irgendwie äh manchmal,
in unserer Szene und nicht nur da eigentlich Menschen allgemein die Tendenz ihre eigene Realität,
bisschen zu wichtig zu nehmen und ich glaube
der ein Untersuchungsausschuss in einem Parlament gemacht hat, ist jetzt nicht irgendwie relevant für die Rechtsänderung und es steht ja da, dass,
Untersuchungsausschussgesetz orientiert sich an der Strafprozessordnung und da steht das ja drin und das jetzt irgendwie zu ändern
ähm nur deswegen, ich glaube beim nächsten Mal wird man darüber nachdenken und das bei,
in Erinnerung haben, wenn halt Leute dabei sind, die äh von diesem Ausschuss wissen, das ist ja auch nicht immer so, gibt ja auch neue Abgeordnete, die mit den al,
Legislaturperioden nichts zu tun haben, aber das Problem ist doch schon viel früher, auch die anderen Ausschüsse, die es im Bundestag so gibt, äh bis auf den,
Agenda Ausschuss, der öfters mal öffentlich tagt, aber so ein Innenausschuss, Justizausschuss, die sind auch per Dieford nicht öffentlich und nur wenn's den Grund gibt, tagen die auch immer öffentlich
Also das jetzt nur wegen unseren Protokollen,
sofort ein Umdenken stattfindet, glaube ich nicht, aber wenn's das nächste Mal in so eine,
auf so ein heikles Thema kommt, wo man so eine große Öffentlichkeit annimmt. Wahrscheinlich denkt man mal darüber nach ob das dann eine andere Konsequenz hat.
Also ich bin ja eher ich bin ja eher Berufspessimist.
Es wäre für die, also ich glaube das einzige Argument, was wirklich eine Rolle spielen,
könnte ist, was du gerade sagst, dass im Zweifelsfall, wenn dir das einfach jeden jedes Mal
Tag später Volltext irgendwo auf ihrer Bundestagsseite vergraben hätten,
hätte das bei weitem nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, weil schon diese Ansage irgendwie so, okay, da sind
da sind irgendwie so ein paar Journalisten, die gehen da jedes Mal hin, die protokollieren jedes Wort mit, weil das äh weil das irgendwie unter dieser absurden
Öffentlichkeit stattfindet, die zwar gegeben sein muss, aber nicht weitergetragen werden darf. Ähm.
Ich stelle mir vor allem mal vor.
Story hat einfach gezogen und hat halt irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit da drauf,
Weil das so ein bisschen dieses ah O, da wird etwas besprochen, da da gibt's kein Protokoll so. Da musst du zur Netzpolitik org gehen, äh um zu gucken, was da los war. Ich glaube, das das hat halt einfach eine ganz andere.
Ich hab ja vor allem, ihr habt euch ja total bemüht sozusagen das, was wirklich gesagt wurde zu protokollieren.
Die Wahrheit hier im. Genau. Jetzt stellt euch mal vor, es gibt jetzt einen Untersuchungsausschuss, der so politisch ein bisschen anders gelagert ist, ja? Und wir haben da jetzt irgendwie so eine Breitbart äh artige Institution, die dann ihre Blogger da reinschickt
und auch ein Protokoll anfügt, was allerdings mit dem Wasser tatsächlich gesagt wird.
Nur begrenzt äh deckungsgleich ist.
Das ist dann sozusagen die einzige Quelle. Das wäre wahrscheinlich noch ein viel größeres Problem,
Ihr hättet da einfach mal die ganze Zeit nur Scheiße erzähl,
Da hätten sie die Protokolle schon veröffentlichen müssen, allein um das irgendwie klarzustellen.
Ich glaube, noch ein Punkt ist
nicht nur, dass Leute da draußen die Protokolle lesen. Ähm ich würde auch echt mal interessieren, wie viele Leute das denn regelmäßig getan haben, wie viele Leute das regelmäßig gelesen haben. Also ich habe zum Beispiel nicht alle von Anna gelesen. Äh ich habe ja nur,
knapp über die Hälfte der Sitzungen gemacht, weil das einfach ein Haufen Holz ist,
und ich frage mich, ob's da draußen mehr als fünf Leute gibt, die das tatsächlich alle gelesen haben,
sowie mit dem Abschlussbericht von dem Ausschuss, aber schon allein, dass wir da jedes Mal da waren und jedes Mal von Anfang bis Ende zugehört haben,
auch am wenigsten inhaltlich verpasst haben, äh, werden die
Protokolle als PDFs irgendwo gelandet, ich hab mit meinem Arbeitsalltag, ich hätte mir die auch nicht durchgelesen, um denn jetzt äh zu gucken, was da so los ist, also ganz unmittelbar, das für mich dazu geführt, dass wir halt.
Äh von dem, was da passiert, auch äh dranbleiben äh und auf Höhe der Zeit bleiben, was der Ausschuss äh so macht, so ganz egoistisch gedacht,
unabhängig davon, wie viele Leute jetzt wirklich jedes Wort äh von diesen Live-Dingern gelesen haben.
Ich denke auch, dass das äh eine eine Rolle spielt. Ich habe das,
gemerkt die wenigen Male, die ich da war. Ähm.
Wenn man das nicht mitprotokolliert und wenn man sich nicht,
damit fest beschäftigt, dann ist das auch schwierig die Aufmerksamkeit über diese Zeit zu halten. Also man man schweift einfach irgendwann ab, man ähm der sich ja auch einfach mal teilweise wirklich eine dreiviertel Stunde passiert da,
inhaltlich
wirklich wenig und wenn man dann, dann verpasst man vielleicht mal ganz kurz den Moment, ne? Also wenn man dann nicht aktiv drin drin involviert ist, so wie die Leute, die da unten sitzen und gerade die Fragen stellen
Das sind ja dann immer die Leute, die gerade nicht twittern. Ähm.
Also wenn oder wie Andre oder so da sitzt und,
protokoliert, was da gesagt wird, dann ist das tatsächlich schwierig, die aufmerksam
zu halten und ich glaube, daran liegt das auch, dass viele der Journalisten ähm.
Am am Morgen kommen und vielleicht nicht bis zum Abend bleiben. Weil die dann ihre Story ungefähr haben und ähm,
die dann eben veröffentlichen und nicht mehr äh dem gesamten Teil folgen können oder folgen wollen.
Du hattest eine schöne Statistik in deinem Artikel, wie viele Millionen Zeichen ihr da getippt habt.
Unsere Live-Blogs haben fünf Komma sechs Millionen Zeichen.
Sechsundsechzig Live-Blogs der Livesitzungen. Das sind.
Dreitausendsiebenhundert sogenannte Nomenseiten oder vierunddreißig Mal das Grundgesetz, habe ich ausgerechnet.
Dreitausendvierhundert Normseiten, also sieben.
Tausendsiebenhundert Normseiten.
Siebeneinhalb äh Pakete Kopiererpapier. Oder wie groß ist.
Ja genau, früher hat man das in Metern A vier Seiten ausgerissen in so ein Zeug, ja.
Regalmeter.
Die Frage ist, wie viele Fußballfelder ist das groß, wenn wir diese Seiten dem anderen.
Bis zum Mond. Nee, nicht ganz.
Tollst soll es Krieg und Frieden sind tausendfünfhundert Seiten oder so, aber ich glaube eine Nomen Seite ist ein bisschen großzügiger in wie viel äh Buchstaben da jetzt tatsächlich auf eine Seite fassen. Also ich habe den Vergleich dann doch nicht getraut, aber mit dem Grundgesetz habe ich's mal,
nebenan gerechnet. Und sechshundertdreizehn Stunden waren die öffentlichen Anhörungen, das ist äh das sind irgendwie achtundzwanzig, siebenundzwanzig Tage oder so am Stück mal vierundzwanzig Stunden.
Waren wir da drin.
Zig Tage.
Nein, äh fast einem Monat äh siebenundzwanzig, achtundzwanzig Tage sechshundertdreizehn Stunden.
Ach so, Entschuldigung, ja. Mhm.
Du hast auch hier diese Statistiken von Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Habt ihr länger gesendet als wir da drin saßen?
Würde mich jetzt echt mal interessieren. Ich ich also quasi was dauert, was geht schneller.
NS Auer oder Logbuch? Also würde mich echt mal interessieren.
Meistens im Schnitt oder was?
Es gibt du kannst auch hier in diesem Pot Love Analytics steht irgendwie die Gesamtdauer aller Episoden.
Ja ja.
Du weißt, dass Tim jetzt Äpfel, Birnen vergleicht und bei ihm Äpfel immer gewinnen, ne.
Elf Komma acht Tage.
Also alle Logbuchnespolitik verfolgen.
In fünf Jahren und wir saßen da in knapp drei Jahren so um die sechsundsiebenundzwanzig Tage drin.
Ihr wart aber nicht so gut unterhalten wie bei Lokbuch Netzkritik.
Das ist deine subjektive Einschätzung.
Zumindest musstet ihr nicht so viele re.
Genug äh genug des Vorgeplankets der Untersuchungsauftrag.
Worum ging's da überhaupt diese drei Jahre und siebenundzwanzig, diese siebenundzwanzig äh Norm Tage.
In in äh in drei Jahren.
Ja, das ist ja schön, dass ich äh gleichberechtigter Gast bin. Äh ich bin mal so ganz egoistisch und frage euch mal, worum ging's denn da eigentlich? Was hat, was sollte der Ausschuss denn eigentlich machen? Was ist denn so die nicht nur öffentliche, sondern auch zumindest
die Wahrnehmung der Leute, die sich damit um schon mal beschäftigt haben. Was war denn der Auftrag? Was solltet ihr denn rausfinden.
Der der Auftrag waren glaube ich dreizehn Einzelne, ne. Wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Dreißig Fragen hier.
Einunddreißig.
Ähm die.
Der der Kernpunkt war natürlich zu gucken, okay, inwiefern agiert,
die NSA in Deutschland gegen deutsche Ziele,
und dann natürlich das, was eigentlich relevant ist, natürlich auch die Frage, inwiefern ähm,
sind da, BND und sogar unter Umständen andere deutsche Geheimdienste.
An der Kooperation eine in einer Kooperation in einer Kooperation ähm vertieft und wer ist dafür verantwortlich? Wer jetzt so meine drei Kernthemen.
Und auch wie welche Schlüsse man daraus ziehen kann, wie man sich äh dagegen besser schützen kann, dass man äh ausgeforscht wird von den bösen TM.
Genau, ich habe ja ähm Freitag so ein äh.
Als Kommentar zum
Ende des Ortsschutzes Hoffnetzpolitik gepostet. Ähm,
mir auch nochmal den Untersuchungsauftrag rausgekramt und den Ausschuss gibt's ja nur
wegen Snoten. Nur wegen den Snotenenthüllungen. Wir erinnern uns, das ist dieses vor dreieinhalb Jahren. Diese fast täglichen.
Megameldungen äh, dass jeden Tag wieder ein Überwachungsprogramm sondergleichen an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist,
Wofür man früher immer gehört hat,
bist ja abgedrehter Aluhut. Äh was hast du denn geraucht, dass du auf so eine Paranoia kommst,
und dann haben wir monatelang erfahren, dass das passiert und zwar noch krasser, als es wir uns vorgestellt haben. Es sind Untenentfüllungen. Da war einmal halbes Jahr Aufregung und das hat wirklich jeden beschäftigt.
Ganz klar unabhängig vom Wahlkampf, auch wenn das natürlich damit,
kurinstitiert hat, das muss untersucht werden. Wir müssen rausfinden, was passiert denn da? Was machen die bösen Geheimdienste der anderen,
Und was wussten deutsche Stellen davon? Und was haben deutsche Stellen eventuell nicht dagegen unternommen oder sogar mitgewirkt? Und dann genau die anderen Fragen,
wie können wir uns schützen, welche Konsequenzen gibt und so. Aber das muss man sich nochmal irgendwie in Erinnerung holen. Markus Becker hat damals öfters mal den Claim gebracht. Wir haben schon über Geheimnisüberwachung,
Da war es Norden noch bei der CIA und wir werden noch über Geheimnisüberwachung berichten, wenn,
niemand mehr interessiert, weil eine Zeit lang war das wirklich das beherrschende Thema,
Der Logo hat jede Woche äh großartig auf Spon gerantet,
Und wir waren alle völlig fasziniert von diesem Thema da draußen wusste jeder worum es geht und heute ist echt so.
Snotenentfüllung. Ja, da war ja mal was irgend so eine Fußnotiz der Geschichte.
Dass wir das mit Facebook.
Das mit Angry Birds, sogar Angry Birds haben sie abgehört.
Stimme zu. Das das war wirklich ein Skandal.
Unglaublich ey.
Und heute ist halt dieses Thema,
wenn nicht Merkel im Ausschuss ist, saßen wir dazu,
zwölf die üblichen Verdächtigen äh ausm Blogger Universum und auch bei uns in der Szene irgendwie ich hab selber langsam
ein bisschen Ermüdungserscheinungen. Es ist irgendwie neue BND-Operationen ab sind. Ja, mein Gott, über Geheimdienste überwachen, ist das jetzt noch so eine News oder nicht? Wenn man stumpft halt ab, ne, aber eigentlich
geht das? Gar nicht.
Unsere Demokratie ist in Gefahr, weil wir uns nicht frei unsere Meinung bilden und kommunizieren können, weil Geheimnis,
Überwachung und das sollte der Ausschuss ähm aufklären.
Investigativ herausfinden und dann eigentlich das Problem lösen,
Und das äh ist irgendwie so die Quintessenz meines hat er nicht geschafft. An an die Geheim an die große Geheimnisüberwachung der Five Eyes, also USA,
Großbritannien, aber auch Kanada, Australien, Neuseeland, ähm ist ja nicht rangekommen, aus diversen Gründen.
Ähm müsste ich den Artikel vorlesen, das ist ziemlich langweilig, aber die haben zum Beispiel keinen einzigen Politiker aus USA oder Großbritannien jemals vernommen. Keinen Geheimdienst äh.
Keine keines der betroffenen Unternehmen, oder.
Nicht mal genau, wir erinnern uns an Prison, äh, zweites Notenenentfüllung vom fü,
der sechsten Juni zwanzig dreizehn,
neun Firmen sind Teil des Prison-Programms, wo die NSA direkten Zugriff auf ihre Server hat. Unter anderem Google, Apple, Microsoft, Facebook, äh.
Nee, Amazon nicht, das ist mir damals aufgefallen, warum auch immer die das nicht fallen. Skype war noch dabei, weil das da noch nicht zu Microsoft gehört hat. Ähm Drop,
Aber,
Chefs der Firmen haben damals, dass sich der Ausschuss gegründet hat, ja Deutschlandausschuss, also wir haben ja nichts zu verbergen, das war alles gar nicht so, wir kommen gerne vorbei und stehen Rede und Antwort,
vor ein, zwei Monaten oder so hat der Ausschuss die eingeladen und dann haben sie überlegt, die hätten irgendwie so die,
Riege, der Lobbyisten in Deutschland geschickt, aber noch nicht öffentlich.
Und da hat der Ausschuss gesagt, also verarschen können wir uns selber. Also nicht mal die Firmen sind gekommen,
klar, der ist ein deutscher Ausschuss und deutsche Bürger sind gesetzlich verpflichtet, da Ladungen anzunehmen.
Ausländer halt nicht ist halt so mit,
internationalen Rest, aber trotzdem angesichts der Groß,
angetreten ist, ähm ist das schon ziemlich ja,
Ich find's schade.
Also um die Five Eyes ging's ziemlich wenig über das, was die NSA tagtäglich macht, über die Glasfasern, die äh das Chese Q, äh, abhört und auch die NSA,
über das Datencenter in Utah, über Peter, beidweise Daten, die jeden Tag weggespeichert werden, ging's so gut wie gar nicht.
Aber jetzt hast du genau, da da ging's gar nicht drum, ne? So haben wir da haben wir in dem Bereich irgendwas Neues gelernt, auch so ähm,
technische Themen wurden ja durchaus da mal ähm behandelt, ne? Also,
Frank Rieger war mal da, hat irgendwie über über,
Abhörtechniken gesprochen. Der Chaos-Computerclub hat irgendwie mal ein Gutach,
zu diesen IP-Adressen beigesteuert. Ähm.
Technische Themen sind jetzt welche, die du natürlich äh auch auch gut verstehst. Würdest du sagen, dass in diesem Bereich irgendwas,
irgendwas mal irgendwie großartig rausgekommen ist, außer irgendwelche Zahlen, wo man dann noch immer die Einheit nicht wusste, ne? Also irgendwie Verkehre oder Prozente von Leitungen, aber so mal richtig einfach technisch
so läuft das und so nicht, gab's da irgendwelche neuen Informationen.
Es ist jetzt ein bisschen abstrakt. Ich habe das jetzt sehr eingeleitet mit dem Auftragsnotenenthüllungen und Five Eis.
Zu dem, was die Dienste von denen von den Ländern machen, gab es so gut wie gar nichts. Ähm weil eben niemand da war,
mehr als Zeitungswissen hatte. Wenn man mal von äh Thomas Trake und äh William Pinny abzieht, zwei
NSA Whistleblower, die aber auch schon äh so um zweitausendeins rum aufgehört haben, die da quasi Inside hatten von wie die Ticken und was damals so äh Stand war, die aber von den ganzen Snotenzeug, was irgendwie nach Eleven,
und vor allem unter Obama mega in Fahrt aufgenommen hat,
auch nicht so wirklich viel wussten. Ähm.
Und und eben all die Sachverständigen äh aus UK und US, die hatten halt auch nur Zeitungswissen,
aber ein extrem gutes technisches und juristisches Verständnis. Die Kunden das den Abgeordneten erklären,
Es kamen tatsächlich auch technische Details ans Licht, die vorher manchen Experten wahrscheinlich bewusst waren,
aber,
jetzt wissen halt all die Abgeordneten und auch die Leute im Kanzleramt und auch alle Leute im BND, was ist,
ist. Das ist so irgendwie eins dieser großen Themen in dem Ausschuss gewesen,
Selektor ist ein ein auf Deutschland hieß es früh äh in Deutschland auf Deutsch hieß das früh,
Kommunikationsmerkmal oder auch Suchbegriff,
da sind so.
Das wo nachgegrippt wird, oder? Also.
So ungefähr, äh das ist das, wonach,
Glasfaser und die Satelliten und was auch immer sie alles abschnurscheln,
inhaltlich durchsucht werden. Die Meterdaten werden ja komplett weggespeichert und inhaltlich wird dann halt geguckt,
Also von diesen Telefonnummern und diesen E-Mail-Adressen, wenn die Teil einer Kommunikation sind,
auch im Inhalt einer Kommunikation,
dann speichern wir den Inhalt der Kommunikation weg, aber Selektoren sind halt bei weitem nicht nur äh E-Mail-Adressen und Telefonnummern, wo es oft ging, sondern es geht hin zu
Browser IDs, Cookie IDs, Gerätenumern, E-Mails, MacAdressen und so bisschen zu Kreditkartennummern, äh Cookie Identifiern, also da gab's eine Snotenfolie mit über dreißig,
Ähm,
Selektoren und bis März zwanzig fünfzehn diese sind im ganzen Ausschusseli,
oder das habe ich noch nie gehört, wie, da gibt's eine Snowdenfolie dazu, hat Merkel im letzten Schätzung gesagt, also ich weiß immer noch nicht genau, was eine Selector ist,
Gab's ja auch keine Sortenfolie zu, oder? Und die Ausschuss doch. Ich habe die dann auch verlinkt im Protokoll. Ähm,
und das wird äh das das Konzept wie diese.
In den Geheimdienst sprech Erfassung diese Fernmeldeaufklärung wie es da so schön heißt eben der Abgriff einer Glasfaser oder an den Zetelliten
funktioniert, das sei wirklich einmal in Bulg, milliardenfach,
Geräte der Geheimdienste,
Im Ausschuss meistens thematisiert in die vom äh BMD ging und dann eben durchsucht wurde nach,
oder auch Inhaltsdingen, nein das ist ein Jahr, was war's? Vor vier Jahren hat der BND in seiner öffentlichen äh Rechtfertigungsbericht an die G zehn Kommissionen, wo er schreibt, wie viele Suchbegriffe er gefunden
dann war sie auf einmal siebenunddreißig Millionen Mails, die die in einem Jahr durchsucht hätten und dann sie, ja, das war Spam und so Spam-Filter, haben nicht funktioniert,
und irgendwann zwischendrin war, wir haben eine zeitweise mal Bombe als Suchbegriff aufgenommen,
das war ein völliger Bullshit, weil das war alles voll mit sechs Bombe und deswegen mussten wir das wieder.
Deswegen mussten wir das wieder rausnehmen,
aber eigentlich durchsuchen sie milliardenfache Kommunikation, um eben angeblich nur ein paar hundert oder tausendfach äh pro Tag,
die Kommunikationsinhalte der Terroristen zu durchsuchen, aber schon allein die Unterscheidungen nehmen Inhalte, die haben auch immer nur davon geredet, Inhalte und nur die Suchbegriffe, die genehmigt wurden, aber das ist eben auch so eine,
ungenehmigte Routine äh Fernmeldeaufklärung nimmst. Sie ginnt quasi das Abgreifen von ganzen Daten äh.
Von denen man zu pauschal sagt, die sind im Ausland, also auch im virtuellen Ausland, in Frankfurt, am Dezix,
ähm und dass man nicht nur auf die Inhaltsdaten aus sind, sondern die Metada,
also wann wer mit wem kommuniziert, Vorrats,
Speicherung einmal komplett hundert Prozent in Burg wegspeichert außer ein paar rausgefilterte Deutsche,
Das war schon eine neue Erkenntnis in ihrem Ausschuss, zumindest für mich, der sich vorher mit dem Thema auch mal beschäftigt,
Problem ist nur, da werden wir dann beim Fazit nochmal drauf kommen. Ja, wir wissen das jetzt und jetzt wurde es halt legalisiert, ne? Äh.
Ja
Ist nicht so, dass dass deswegen geändert wurde, die Praxis.
Du hast gerade ähm.
Ich denke, dass es auch so ein sehr schöner, ein sehr schöner Aspekt dieses Ausschusses. Äh du hast gerade virtuelles Ausland gesagt,
Und es gibt eine ganze Reihe ähm von derartigen.
Neuen Konzepten oder vielleicht für die Öffentlichkeit zumindest neuen Konzepten,
die ja auch im in dem Vortrag, den Anna und du beim dreiunddreißig C drei darüber gehalten habt an dieser Stelle nochmal kurz erwähnt werden soll. Ähm
so vorgestellt hat. Also virtuelles Ausland ist eine.
Ist einer davon, also man sitzt am am Internetknoten, D-Kicks und sagt äh ja,
das ist zwar hier Frankfurt, ähm, aber die Daten, die hier durchfließen, die gehen ja quasi sehr international, also ist das jetzt zwar nicht Ausland, aber virtuelles Ausland und deswegen gilt hier
dass das Recht das deutsche Recht nicht mehr.
Genau, das ist eine von vielen gewagten Rechtstheorien, die sich der BND selber ausgedacht hat. Ähm,
Gibt ja das Problem, es gibt halt Gesetze und R,
und die werden von Politikern gemacht, die davon bisschen Grundverständnis haben,
Und dann steht da dieses Gesetz in der BND, muss irgendwie gucken, ja wie kriege ich denn jetzt, was ich machen möchte und,
denke machen zu müssen, in Einklang mit dem Recht und da muss man das recht manchmal ganz schön,
frei und hart interpretieren und auslegen. Was wir auch Snoten gelernt haben, also was ist da,
genauso für Rechtskonstrukte gar vor dem hatten ja dann noch diese,
Gericht, äh was dann Anordnungen macht und eine von dreitausend dann auch mal ablehnt.
Stimmt beides, weil das irgendwie unter Richtervorbehalt war und dann haben sie halt gesagt, okay, dann machen wir ein geheimes Gericht.
Ja, genau, genau, von dem noch nicht mal äh gesagt werden, wo es denn Englischtag. Aber genau
das mit dem virtuellen Ausland das vereinste Probleme, die der BND hatte, im BND-Gesetz steht halt, dass der BND im Ausland tätig werden darf und er darf ja machen, was er will, solange er sich nicht im Ausland erwischen lässt.
Und wenn er dann Daten deutscher äh dabei erfasst, muss er die nach den deutschen Gesetzen äh behandeln,
Ausländer sind vogelfrei, äh wie wir öfters mal so gehört haben, war auch so,
dass bei so ziemlich allen,
Auslandsgeheimdiensten gilt, also die hundertzweiundneunzig oder wie viel wir immer haben aktuell.
Anderen Staaten und deren äh Staatsbürger, also mit denen können wir machen, was wir wollen. Wir müssen halt ein paar unserer Staatsbürger anders behandeln und schützen. Aber im BND-Gesetz stand halt nur, dass der BN im Ausland tätig werden darf und im Innenland
nur mit besonder, nur mit gesonderten äh Maßnahmen, also im Inland und deutsche Überwachung darf der BND nur, wenn's einen konkreten Tatverdacht gibt, dass die auch was mit
oder nicht Tatverdacht, das ist ja keine Strafverfolgung, sondern Anfangsverdach,
dass die auch was mit Terrorismusprodukeration oder mittlerweile ja auch Cyber und so, weswegen der BND Deutsche abhören darf,
zu tun haben und eines der Rechtskonstrukte, was der BND hatte, der wollte damals eben,
Internetknoten in Frankfurt nicht den Dezix, das war später nach zwotausendneun, sondern von der Telekom abhören, in der Operation Eikonal.
Äh ist zur ähm,
zu dem gegangen und haben gesagt, ja, wir wollen einmal.
Möglichst viel, also so dreißig Leitungen oder so eine ordentliche Meinung und die haben gesagt, ja, ihr dürft aber in Deutschland nur Deutsche abhören und nur mit so einer,
G zehn Anordnung, also so eine Anordnung, dass ihr äh Deutsche überwachen dürft und das muss das G zehn Gremium ähm,
so ein G zehn Kommissionen ehrenamtliches Gremium angedoppt im Bundestag. Ähm,
genehmigen, äh, mit den Zielen, die ihr habt und den Suchbegriffen und den Themen quasi. Es muss um wenige Leute rund um Terror,
so ungefähr mal einfach ausgedrückt und die haben dann gemeint, ja wir schreiben euch das mal so auf,
Aber ihr müsst uns dann schon den kompletten Dampf geben, weil wir filtern uns dann die paar deutschen äh,
wir aus dem Milliardenkommunikationsdaten haben und dann als sie aber einmal diesen Zugang hatten haben wir gemeint, ja der Rest ist ja
der rissen ja Ausländer, das ist ja, das ist ja Vogelfrei, damit können wir ja machen,
was wir wollen. Sie haben sich quasi und so hieß das wahrscheinlich auch in internation das als,
Türöffner genommen, äh diese G zehn Maßnahme, die angeordnet wurde
wo drin steht, dass sie fünf Telekommunikationsverkehre von drei Terroristen haben dürfen oder so, um dann die restlichen Milliarden aller Ausländer zu kriegen, was ihr eigentlicher Zweck war,
als die G zehn Kommission rausgefunden hat, dass sie verarscht wurden, haben sie ge.
Fuck. Lieber BMD, so war das nicht ausgemacht. Wir verklagen euch jetzt mal,
wir sehen ab jetzt genauer hin. Äh das war eine dieser interessanten,
Konstrukte des PND. Die anderen wurden ja hier bestimmt schon besprochen, also Weltraumtheorie, das irgendwie,
Bad Aibling, bei den Satelliten gilt kein deutsches Recht, weil die Satelliten, die man abhört, sind ja im Weltraum, obwohl der deutsche Mitarbeiter mit deutschem Strom auf deutschen Boden ein deutsches Essen in der Kantine,
Daten in deutschen Datenbanken verarbeiten und so.
Und die Funktionsträgertheorie, dass man Günther Öttinger abhören darf, weil er ja manch,
EU-Kommissar ist und man da manchmal auch auf Englisch.
Tatsächlich Günther Öttinger abgehört.
Nee, das war das Beispiel, was da immer rumging, es wurden.
Oh Mann.
Es wurden deutsche Diplomaten abgehört. Äh es wurde ähm.
Äh ich komme gerade nicht auf seinen Namen, aber ein EU-Abgesandter sind die Türkei, ein deutscher äh deutscher Topdiplomat wurde abgehört, äh weil eben gesagt wurde, der ist zwar Deutscher und darf also eigentlich nicht vom BND abgehört werden,
Aber hier ist er in seiner Funktion als EU-Repräsentant und er kommuniziert auf englisch oder türkisch oder was auch immer
über eine nicht über eine DE E-Mail Adresse, sondern über eine Punk,
EU E-Mail Adresse, also dürfen wir das, weil er hier in seiner Funktion als,
oder aus Supranationaler äh Repräsentant fungiert und nicht in seiner Funktion als Grundrechtsträger.
Und das sind aber natürlich auch alles äh
also all das sind einfach haarsträubende Interpretationen, oder? Also oder man könnte vielleicht auch äh Rechtsbeugungen sagen oder stand irgendwo explizit äh ja ja, Funktionsträger darf man abhören.
Nee, nee, äh all alle Kontrollgremien, als sie das erfahren haben, also G zehn Kommissionen, parlamentarische Kontrollgremium teilweise bis ins Kanzleramt, haben gesagt,
What, wie, worauf seid ihr denn hier gekommen, wie habt ihr euch denn das äh Gesetz zurechtgebogen.
Aber im BND hat man halt gedacht, ja funktioniert doch.
Merkt ja eh niemand
wird ja kontrolliert ja niemand, weiß ja niemand, dass wir das machen und wenn das jemand rausfindet, dann sagen wir ihm das und manche dieser Theorien, die Funktionsträgertheorie und Weltraumtheorie wurden von manchen Leuten im Kanzleramt sogar gedeckt, aber das Problem war, dass
Die ganzen anderen Leute, die dafür die Kontrolle zuständig waren, eben nicht wussten, wie der BND das Gesetz interpretiert, weil das geheim uminterpretiert hat und den anderen nicht gesagt.
Und jetzt ist es eben rausgekommen und jetzt hieß es, das geht ja gar nicht,
Also hat man jetzt das Gesetz so geändert, dass sie das alles machen dürfen, ohne dass sie diese komischen Konstrukte brauchen.
Also jetzt muss er nicht mal das Recht beugen, jetzt wurde das Recht an die Geheimdienste angepasst.
Das Gesetz stößt gegen, verstößt gegen die Geheimdienste, ist sowieso einer der besten Lokbuchnetzfit.
Den wir hier hatten, ja.
Hatten, ja. Ähm mein,
grundsätzliche Frage, dass der das ein Auslandsgeheimdienst da draußen,
Ähm so gut wie keine Beschränkungen hat äh was hältst du davon,
Also ich persönlich glaube, anders kannst du es ja kaum machen und es gibt ja irgendwie auch gar keinen Grund, ne. Das heißt, du bist dann eben im, in internationalem Gewässer und dann musst du.
Ähm,
also ist klar, dass du dich nicht an das das geltende Recht in anderen Staaten halten wirst. Es sei denn,
einigst dich mit den auf diplomatischen Wege darauf, ne? Also bilaterale,
äh Verträge oder von mir aus ein No-Spy äh
Abkommen oder auch ein Spy-Abkommen wie die Five-Ice, ja? Das kann man alles machen, aber da bist du eben,
in der Einigung zwischen zwei Staaten und natürlich interessiert dich das Recht des anderen Staates,
nicht. Es sei denn, du bindest dich da irgendwie diplomatisch dran. Das heißt aber auch.
Wenn da etwas, wenn gegen deine Interessen verstoßen wird, dass das ein diplomatisches Problem ist,
Das auf diplomatischem Wege geklärt, sanktioniert oder ausdiskutiert werden müsste. Wie siehst du das.
Ja ähnlich, aber es wird nochmal irgendwie die.
Noch ein bisschen auf die Mittebene nehmen? Im.
Immer gut. Danke.
Habe ich nur für dich untergebracht. Ähm.
Zu sagen, jeder und jetzt nutzt man den Begriff jede Nation hat das Recht mit den Bürgern der anderen hundertzweiundneunzig.
Zumindest in der Kommunikation, äh jetzt nicht irgendwie äh Leib und Leben und Freiheitsberaubung und so,
Mit deren Kommunikation zu machen, was sie wollen.
Das mag geltendes, internationales Rechtssender, es ist tatsächlich in internationalen Rech,
verboten. Die Frage ist, wollen wir in so einer Welt leben.
Das affirmiert das Konzept. Wir haben egoistische Nationen.
Die gegeneinander in Konkurrenz sind und für sich jeweils das Beste wollen. America first und dann aber erst alle anderen,
oder haben wir,
Internationale Kooperationen wie eine EU, wie eine UNO und wir arbei,
zusammen und die Überwachung wird uns ja verkauft mit es geht um Terror.
Und gegen Terror sind sich alle einig. Es gibt glaube ich wenig nationale Geheimdienste auf der Welt, die nicht irgendwie gegen den IS äh und islamistischer Anschläge sind,
ähm.
Und uns wird diese ganze Geheimdienste äh Überwachung ja immer verkauft mit es geht gegen Terror. Wenn man wirklich nur gegen Terroristen vorgehen würde, dann bräuchte man einen Bruchteil der Ressourcen,
und man könnte alle zusammenlegen bis auf irgendwie, dann lässt man halt, was weiß ich, ähm,
Iran aber auch aus Saudi-Arabien, Jemen, was auch immer, jetzt mal ein paar Accessoires star.
Genannt raus, mit denen man dann nicht kooperiert. Die haben dann halt ihre eigenen Interessen, aber wenn's wirklich nur gegen Terroristen geht, könnte man das ja,
kollektiv, supranational, meinetwegen auf UNO-Ebene machen oder so,
darum geht's nicht. Das wird immer nur öffentlich gesagt,
auch in Deutschland geht irgendwie Terrorismus und auch Prolefteration, Waffenhandels sind irgendwie höchstens ein Fünftel oder so der ganzen Überwachungsziele. Es geht um Geldfälschung, es geht um Drogen, es geht um ganz großes Thema Schleusung,
also die Ausländer dürfen hier nicht mehr Reinfestung Europa äh und es geht mittlerweile um Cyber und es geht ganz klar um Macht. Es geht darum,
es geht um diplomatische Spionage, es geht darum zu wissen, auf einem internationalen Gipfel, was denken die Chinesen,
ist deren Verhandlungsposition, wenn Merkel und äh Schäuble mit denen zusammentreffen,
und dann sind wir eben beim äh Egoistischen.
Kampf der Nationen statt,
Bei dem gemeinsamen Terrorismusabwehr und äh wenn man das mit dem Konkurrenzkraft der Nationen gut findet, dann will man natürlich diese Dienste so haben und so ist diese Welt da draußen. Nur so wird uns das nicht erklärt und eigentlich, wenn's gegen den Terror geht, könnte man das viel einfacher
kollektive und auch legitimer machen, äh weil da gibt's wenig Leute, die das dann auch noch kritisieren würden.
Die Zusammenarbeit wird aber natürlich gerade bei Kampf gegen den Terror dann doch,
immer wieder ja auch benannt, ne? Also
das, ich erinnere mich, dass Altmaier ja denn auch ausführlich sagte so, ne? Also dadurch, dass wir mit der NSA kooperieren, ne,
haben wir eben diese ähm haben wir einen sehr viel besseren Kampf gegen den Terror und konnten Anschläge verhindern oder sowas, ne? Also ich weiß nicht, ob er das jetzt
explizit nochmal mit den Anschlägen verhindern, so gesagt hat, aber ich weiß, dass ähm.
Äh dem Maisier, das natürlich auch regelmäßig mal anbringt, äh dass hier sozusagen die Kooperation der Geheimdienste gegen Terror ist notwendig. Gleichzeitig, wenn sie's dann aber gegen,
Wenn es sich dann gegen uns als Bürger richtet.
Äh dann haben wir natürlich keinen Bock drauf, ne? Da kommt dieser dieses schöne Modell des Ringtausches,
ja ein Spiel, wo wir vielleicht auch nochmal ganz kurz drüber sprechen sollten.
Regentausch.
Ringtausch der Geheimdienste? Ja, heißt du? Ja, du hast.
Nicht. Etwas. Ein Ring sieht zu knecht.
Die tragen alle diese Ringe an der Hand,
ja, so Altmaier kommt in NS Auer, ne? Und der hat auch der rechten Faust so ein sieht aus wie ein Schlagring,
so NSA GCH, BND, äh, Forever steht auf der nein.
Leuchtet das auch auf, wenn man den abnimmt, so.
Das ist der One Tour the Moll, den trägt Trump.
Ich kann kein, was war die Sprache? Elbe Schnee.
Geht ein bisschen weit weg, Ringtausch. Ist das Konzept.
Ähm eben Geheimdienste, die eigenen Bürger nicht abhören dürfen,
Aber alle anderen? Und wenn jetzt,
Der dänische Geheimnis, keine Dänen abhören, aber darf aber die Deutschen und die Deutschen keine deutschen Abhören dürfen, aber die dehnen, kann man danach ja eine gemeinsame Datenbank machen,
Und dann hat man wieder alles. Ähm um das Konzept Ringtausch.
Viel, also zumindest äh gingen einige der Fragen in dem Untersuchungsauftrag und es wurde immer mal gefragt, gibt's das oder nicht? Es gab aber immer nur eine Antwort, die hieß, nein, natürlich nicht, weil das dort so definiert wird mit wirklich Staaten, die der eigene Dienst nicht,
selbst erheben darf, die der dann hintenrum in Burg von einem anderen Dienst,
bekommt. Ich habe jetzt keine Beweise.
Äh bekommen, dass es in äh dass es tatsächlich so passiert ist unter Mitwirkung des BND.
Weil ich einfach nicht weiß, ob die tatsächlich Daten Deutscher in Bulg von NSA oder anderen bekomme, weil man hat ja nicht rausgefunden, genau was die NSA macht.
Ähm der Ringtausch eher als Konzept von Umgehung der eigentlichen äh der,
eigenen Rechtsnorm des eigentlichen Rechtsrahmens,
wurde da so nicht belegt. Der Tausch.
Von massenhaft Daten, um die in eine gemeinsame Datenbank zu schmeißen. Das aber schon. Äh das gibt's immer wieder. Äh bei den diversesten Kooperationen. Also angefangen damit.
Und das, da wird auch das allermeiste von dem Terror damit begründet ist ja Deutschland gemeinsam mit den USA und der ISAF in Afghanistan
theoretisch gewesen, praktisch immer noch. Ähm,
und die meisten Terroristen, die gefangen werden, sind Leute, die in Afghanistan eine Roadsi,
vergraben haben, um die gegen äh die Soldaten einzusetzen,
Dort haben sie zum Schutz von der Truppe äh als Eigensicherung schmeißen eben alle ICF-Dienste äh ihre Überwachung zusammen, eine große Datenbank und da ist der BND ganz vorne mit dabei. Marca Isharif und die nehmen da wohl einmal das komplette Mobilfunknetz,
und sind da richtig aktiv und schmeißen das dann in einen gemeinsamen Topf und das werden dann die ganzen,
Eishoffenmilitär ist gemeinsam aus und so werden auch fünfundneunzig Prozent der Terroristen gefangen. Es geht da nicht um irgendjemand,
Europa einen Krassenanschlag plant, äh sondern,
den Krieg in Afghanistan, um den Schutz der engen äh Truppe,
Und da werden dann auch äh so eine riesigen gemeinsamen Datenbanken.
Da geht's nochmal weniger um Ringtauschen im Sinne davon, dass zu dann Daten deutscher Bürger landen,
Zweites Beispiel ist aber auch, die Operation Eikonal, eine der wenigen Operationen, die der Ausschuss äh ähm analysieren durfte, weil es muss mehrere Kriterien erfüllen, das musste der BND mit,
Einem Dienst der Five Eis machen, aber mit keinem anderen und es musste äh schon abgeschlossen sein,
schon allein diese diese Einschränkung hat dazu geführ,
äh das wirklich nur ein Bruchteil dessen, was der BND gemacht hat und macht,
wirklich gesehen werden darf, ganz zu schweigen von mal,
untersucht. Ähm.
Hier, sie machen da was was Illegales. Ja, aber das, das tun wir ja noch, deswegen dürfen wir da jetzt nicht drüber.
Untersuchungsauftrag nicht der Untersuchungszeitraum nicht der und so weiter und so fort, was da immer eng.
Lassen sie mich erstmal zu Ende machen, ja.
Genau, lass mich erst zu Ende morgen.
Bei der Operation Eikonal, da ging's halt äh darum, dass der BND in äh Frankfurt am Telekom Internet knoten,
Daten rastert.
Aber gemeinsam mit der NSA, da wurden diese vierzehn Millionen Selektoren eingestreut und das landete die Meterdaten komplett in einer Datenbank
mit so einem mehr schlechter als recht funktionierenden Filter von deutscher Kommunikation. Und diese Daten sind dann täglich an die NSA,
Also die haben den kompletten Stash bekommen von Meterraten und ausgesuchten Inhaltsdaten, was der BND äh,
Telekom in Frankfurt gerastet hat.
Die ähm NSA das jetzt äh erheben durfte, also nach amerikanischem Recht schon, nach deutschem Recht nicht, weil sie nicht alleine an den äh Frankfurter Internetknoten hätten gehen dürfen. Äh deswegen haben sie ja das zusammen mit dem BND gemacht.
Aber also Ringtausch, wenn man ganz äh genau ist und ähm juristisch hat der.
Der Ausschuss so nicht belegt äh aber jede Menge anderen Datenaustausch, der mindestens genauso problematisch.
Was ist aber denn hier mit diesen Selektoren, die die NSA automatisch den BS,
BND einspielen durfte
und der BD hat problemlos die Daten zurückgeliefert und man hat irgendwie das Pferd festgestellt, dass wir,
der BND für die NSA auf unbestimmte Zei,
äh alles alles mögliche Recht gebrochen hat.
Stimmt, guter Punkt. Ähm.
Also das war für mich eines der ganz großen, eines der ganz großen
Dinger, okay. Kann man jetzt sagen, ist vielleicht keine Ringtausch oder so, ne? Aber da da gab's doch wirklich 'ne, 'ne Kooperation,
also absolut lächerlich.
Äh kontrolliert war, absolut lächerlich ausgestaltet war und wo er dann auf einmal irgendwie auch das füße Scharren losging, als dann ähm selbst als,
graulig dann mal irgendwie in diese Selektoren schaute, ne? Müssen wir jetzt glaube ich gar nicht auskotieren, ob das jetzt ein Ringtausch ist oder nicht, aber äh auf jeden Fall sollten wir mal drauf eingehen
was denn da genau los war.
Genau, das ist eins der Dinge, die der Ausschuss wirklich rauskriegen konnte. Ähm,
Selektoren, das sind diese äh Kommunikationsmer,
wie eine E-Mail-Adresse oder eine Telefonnummer, aber eben auch ein paar Dutzend andere. Und von denen hat die NSA den BND,
vierzehn Millionen gegeben
äh so viele Terroristen gibt's gar nicht. Äh dann gibt's die Ausrede, ja okay, dann haben wir halt zu einer Person auch dreißig, dann haben wir halt das, die Adressbuchdaten mit Adresse, E-Mails, äh Jabby ID oder was auch immer, ist er sonst noch äh so da drin hatten,
es sind trotzdem noch jede Menge. Der hat Bier, BND täglich von Server, der NSA geholt und dann in seiner sogenannte Erfassung.
Eingesteuert. Ich habe jetzt hier eher kurz äh gemacht, wie das so schön im Geheimdienstsprech hat. Hat quasi in seinen Glasfasern die er in Frankfurt abgreift und in den Satellitenstrecken,
die er abgreift, nicht nur die Meter, der hat einen komplett,
sondern auch in den inhaltlichen Kommunikationsdaten, also um den,
rufen, faxen, E-Mails, äh, Jaber-Nachrichten, Shop, Messages, Facebo
was auch immer alles äh kommuniziert wird heutzutage digital. Äh danach nach diesen Telekommunikationsteilnehmern und teilweise sogar Suchbegriffen wie Worten, eben Bombe, sechs Bombe und so,
gesucht,
das alles weggespeichert, die Kommunikation, die da Ergebnisse getroffen hat und das wiederum automatisch an die NSA gegeben. Das stimmt,
und als danach Snowden und nach dem NSA und der Aufregung gesag,
ja, wisst ihr denn überhaupt, welche welche Personen die NSA euch da überwachen lässt,
der wenig zugeben müssen äh haben wir noch nicht so drüber nachgedacht. Guter Punkt, gucken wir mal nach. Und dann haben sie nachgeguckt und gemeint, Scheiße hier sind vierzigtausend,
die sind zu deutschen und Europäern und NATO-Partnern, also diesem Ausspähen unter Freunden, die NSA hat uns vierzigtausend Selektoren gegeben
und wir haben unsere Kommunikation danach gerastet, die Kommunikation an die NSA gegeben und wir haben danach festgestellt,
Oh Scheiße, da sind ja auch Deutsche drunter, was tatsächlich für den BND illegal war, für die NSA nicht.
Da wir aber jetzt auch keiner dran schuld, ne?
Natürlich ist es nie jemand an irgendwas Schuld äh vielleicht die NSA, weil sie so frech waren, das probiert zu haben, vielleicht irgendjemand irgendwo im BND, weil wenn man das nicht probiert hat, aber
Man konnte das ja nicht so ganz genau, weil man hat die Technik noch nicht so ganz verstanden, man musste erstmal auf die Höhe der Zeit kommen
Und dann irgendwann hat ja mal irgendjemand nachgeguckt, der hat's halt nur nicht nach oben gemeldet. So ist die ganz große.
Wesentlichen haben die einfach nicht drauf geschaut. Genau. Also es ist einfach.
Unter Freunden, dass es halt wirklich nur um Terroristen ging. Bis man nachgeguckt hat, dass es das nicht tut.
Pass auf, wenn du ein internationaler Spion eines Auslandsgeheimdienstes bist, ne? Und mir mit dem Argument kommst, du hättest jemand anderem vertraut,
Dann weiß ich, dass du mich verarscht. Also ist doch wohl wirklich mal,
ganze Job heißt nicht vertrauen, ja?
Deswegen sagen die auch immer, die haben keine Freunde, sondern nur Partner.
Also.
Aber da sitzen ja keine James Bonds. Ich meine, in zumindest in der technischen Aufklärung, da sitzen halt so
Ingenieure und Nörse, das sind jetzt nicht die Martini und Undercovereinsätze im Ausland, Leute. Obwohl dann ab der,
Führung der Abteilung dann schon. Da kommen dann so gestandene Soldaten und Leute, die,
schon mal Einsatz und Krieg und hinterfeindlichen Linien gesehen haben
aber die einzelnen Sachbearbeiter, die Technik News äh nicht unbedingt, was ist aber nicht entschuldigt,
das ganze System ist rotten, wenn das sich niemand die Frage stellt und das jahrelang niemand auffällt
bis es ein Snoten gibt und dann auch deutsche Politiker noch Druck machen, dass da nachgeguckt wird. Das hat einfach nie jemand nachgeguckt.
Vor allem muss man mal also da jetzt irgendwie zu sagen, okay der technisch wird das von da nach da gezogen. Ähm und da kommt's von der NSL, da kommt's von BND. Technisch ist das glaube ich ähm,
Der Ablauf wäre nicht anders gewesen, wenn dieses Thema einfach allem gehört hätten, nämlich von irgendwo her wird gesagt, folgende Selektoren bitte.
Dann werden die irgendwo in ein System gepult,
werden da zum Einsatz gebracht und werden die Ergebnisse zurückgeliefert. Das heißt.
Also ich glaube, dass das jetzt von der Stadt äh von der ähm von der Architektur,
System nicht anders nicht nennenswert anders gewesen wäre, wenn es,
einfach vollständig der NSA gehört hätte. Ähm mit anderen Worten, die haben da einfach,
Also das nicht nur irgendwie, ah da hat uns jemand einen Selektor untergejubelt, sondern die hatten einfach Vollzugriff, unkontrollierten Vollzugriff auf das System, was wir errichtet haben.
Das ist eine der großen Thesen in dem Ausschuss, dass das bei der Operation Eikonal in Frankfurt tatsächlich so war. Es gibt da so eine berühmte Folie von Konstantin von Notz über Ramper,
so eine Operation äh Snowdenoperationen
wo drin steht auf einer NSA-Folie, sie machen so eine,
Kooperationen mit Datenabgriffen, mit lokalen Partnern im Ausland,
Und da steht aber drin, ja und wir haben dann nochmal einen geheimen Zugriff durch die Hintertür und der Partner äh kriegt davon nichts mit. Ähm,
ob und wie das jetzt bei Elconal war, habe ich selber noch nicht so ganz rausgefunden, es ist ja auch alles ganz streng geheim und äh,
eingestuft und man darf da über auch wenig Details öffentlich reden. Nur aus dem,
aus den Anhörungen hört man, dass da eben manchmal so raus, ist ja nicht so, dass alles, was wir
herausgefunden haben irgendwie die heißen Brocken sind, sondern nur das, was davon öffentlich bekannt geworden ist. Ähm,
Und so war das in dieser Operation, die aber.
Ja auch nicht nur mit der NSA so funktioniert. Äh was ist denn mit was ist denn mit den anderen Diensten, die man nicht untersuchen konnte? Also was ist denn jetzt mit Frankreich äh und Italien und so,
Was ist denn mit Operationen, die noch laufen? Natürlich, da werden die Sedlektoren reingeworfen. Nur es geht halt nicht Selektronen blind zu nehmen,
Also wenn man das Konzept wir,
Glasfasern ab überhaupt gut findet äh und dann die Raster,
aber diese Elektronen blind zu nehmen und jetzt hat der BND ja angeblich auch gelernt und gesagt, okay, wir nehmen jetzt nur noch Selektoren, von dem wir wissen, zu wem sie gehören,
dass sie auch was mit Terror, Waffenhandel, Geldfäschung oder sowas zu tun haben. Eben, dass es ein legitimes,
und legales äh Abhörziel ist. Vorher hatten sie einfach da nicht drauf geguck,
Sind ja auch Selektonen drin wie äh eine J-IDs und mit Jabba ID. Äh irgendwas at Jabba dot org. Ist das jetzt ein Deutscher? Ist das jetzt ein Europäer? DE, nur weil DE da dran steht,
ich hab mal gehört, da haben Haufen Leute die durchaus auf NSL letzte Elektroen sich befinden durften einen Account. Äh wie soll der BND,
das rausfinden. Ähm angeblich jetzt wird das alles ganz gut,
Bei denen, bei denen man's lesen und nachvollziehen kann. Da haben wir man vertraut halt immer noch der NSA, dass sie da das Richtige schreiben. Also wenn der Stand wird auf diesem Hash, auf dieser Schar eins Summe, ist ja jetzt auch gebrochen, aber ähm ist dieses,
Bombenbauanleitungen dahinter oder so, PDF, äh da muss man dem halt trauen.
Wir haben glaube ich nicht ausführlich nochmal gesagt, ja, bei diesen unter diesen Selektoren waren ja vor allem auch sehr viele ähm ja Unternehmen, also eigentlich Wirtschaftsspionageziele.
Das riechst du zwei verschiedene Punkte an. Das erste ist,
haben jetzt über die vierzigtausend Selektonen geredet, die,
Der BND von der NSA bekommen hat.
Die hat nur der Kurt graulich angeguckt und davon wissen wir nichts. Weil das ist alles ganz streng geheim und nur der V-Mann der Bundesregierung durfte die angucken und kein einziger Abgeordneter weder im parlamentarischen Kontrolldrehmum noch im Untersuchungsausschuss noch um sonst irgendwo.
Also Form hat für dich jetzt schön auf ist. Vertrauen.
Das heißt, der der Heißoffiziöse. Ja, Vertrauensperson heißt äh V,
Das ist das Geheimdienstsprich.
Dachte, Forman hieß sie irgendwie für.
Nee, nee, eine Vertrauensperson. Ähm.
Nachdem man gemerkt hat, oh Shit, die NSA-Selektronen sind ja äh,
Von unterschiedlicher Qualität und da sollte man lieber mal nachgucken und als dann auch noch der Ausschuss gemeint hat, ja ja oh jetzt wissen wir das und was ist mit den BND-Selektoren? Hat der BN gedacht, ah ja guter Punkt sollten wir auch mal nachgucken, was wir so selber machen,
unsere Selektonen angucken und dann hat der BND selber nochmal äh,
Fünfzehntausend Selektoren gefunden. Ähm die er selber gesteuert hat,
EU und NATO und Deutsche und Freunde abhören unter Freunden betroffen haben,
rausgenommen, also
nicht mehr danach überwacht, theoretisch und die durfte dann äh eine Tuskforce vom parlamentarischen Kon,
Gremium und manche, ich glaube, die Obleute vom Untersuchungsausschuss im sogenannten Treptow-Verfahren angucken, das heißt, die dürfen
Kanzleramt oder in die BND Zentrale gehen, die Liste angucken, aber dürfen's keine Notizen machen und mitnehmen, keine Handys dabei haben,
und kein nichts und dürfen natürlich nicht darüber sprechen, weil alles ganz streng geheim. Aber als Paar von denen.
Fünfzehntausend Selektonen, die der BND selber gegen Ausspähnen unter Freunden ähm,
gesetzt habe. Da kam eine große Liste raus,
auch deutsche Botschafter, äh deutsche Botschaften, deutsche Diplomaten,
Außenminister von Frankreich, die Knesse denn Israel ähm Netanjahu äh ich könnte das jetzt alles vorlesen. Die Süddeutsche hat gemeint, Zitat so ziemlich jede europäische Regierung, manchmal wie in Österreich bis zum bis runter zum Agrarministerium,
und unter diesen riesen Liste, wo auch irgendwie ein Haufen UNO-Organisation, internationale Währungsfonds, Weltgesundheitsorganisation, Unicef,
rotes Kreuz, Strafgerichtshof Opek, USZE, Ochsfarm,
Welthungerhilfe und so drin ist und wie wir am Freitag noch vom Spiegel gelernt haben, Journalisten von BBC, New York Times und Reuters,
sind auch Wirtschaftsunternehmen mit dabei, äh, nicht nur Banken und Ratingagenturen, sondern eben auch Eurocopter, ERDS und Lockhead.
Du hast jetzt gesagt, dass das Wirtschaftsspionage, ich würde das ähm intuitiv auch so sagen, dann ist aber die Ausrede immer, nein, das kann man nicht,
Als Wirtschaftsspionage bezeichnen, den
erstens, wir machen das ja nur, weil's um äh Pro Liferation geht, also um weiter Verbreitung von Waffen, zum Beispiel, wenn irgendwie eher der Steelings mit.
Teil von die auch als Waffen verwendet werden können in Krisenstaaten wie Iran, äh Ex,
portiert, wo Exportrestriktionen sind.
Und wir machen das ja nur um den Waffenhandel zu unterbinden und nicht um wirtschaftliche Interessen,
rauszufinden und Wirtschaftsspionage wär's nur, wenn wir wirtschaftlich relevante Daten haben und die dann Unternehmen geben, die das für ihre wirtschaftlichen Zwecke nutzen.
Wirtschafts äh Politik,
wiederum geht klar, Bankenrating Agenturen, andere Staaten wie Finanzminister, andere Staaten zu untersuchen, äh um für die,
Wirtschaftskraft Deutschlands, um auch Wirtschaftsabkommen und zur Wirtschaftspolitik ist keine Wirtschaft,
weil Wirtschaftsspionage ist es nur, wenn wir das dann im Unternehmen konkret geben und das dann
quasi gegen seinen Konkurrenten nutzt. Also das ist wieder eine Definitionsfrage,
Wenn du den Ausschuss fragst, gibt's keine Wirtschaftsspionage, es gibt nur die Spionage von Wirtschaftspolitik.
Mit Definitionen ist das sowieso äh so eine Sache in dem Ausschuss,
Was normalerweise Leute da draußen verstehen, so wie nur Speicherabkommen wird da drin komplett anders äh verstanden,
sowie die NSA haben wir ja bei Snowden gelernt, wie Überwachung, nee, nee, wir überwachen nichts, wir wir speichern alles,
Aber Überwachung ist ja erst, wenn das ein Mensch dann auch anhört oder anguck.
Weil es wird vorselektiert, wir überwachen ganz, ganz wenig. Nur erst wenn der Computer sagt, hier.
Schau mal auf den Bildschirm.
Ja.
Tja. Na ich meine,
Problem bisschen mit den Geheimdiensten ist, die anderen machen's auch, ne? Und da wollen natürlich äh äh keiner keiner will sozusagen zurückstehen. Niemand wird das versprechen, wir geben dir Informationen auf dessen Basis, du besser
Anführungsstrichen besser Politik machen kannst. Ähm dem Widerstehen, so. Das.
Ist einfach ein globales Menschheitsproblem. Ich meine, gibt's denn irgendwie gibt's einen Staat, der keinen hat.
Also es gibt Staaten, die überhaupt keine strukturierten Strukturen.
Also sagen wir mal ja gut, aber wenn sie, wenn sie erstmal eine haben, dann ist das wahrscheinlich eine der ersten, die sie haben.
Naja, es gibt ja auch hier so eine Diskussion mit Armeen, es gibt ja Costa Rica als Beispiel für den Staat, dass keine Armee hat, äh die dann aber eben auch unter dem Schutz des großen Bruders, äh, USA stehen, wobei sich fragt, ob das jetzt immer noch so ist.
Ja, ja. Ja, dann haben sie nämlich auch bald eine.
Und es gibt halt ähm ich
Ich habe das selber nicht nachgeprüft, aber vor kurzem hat mir jemand von der belgischen Repräsentanz in Brüssel gesagt, also deren Geheimdienste sind total unterfinanziert und die können sich wirklich nur um Terror äh kümmern, ob das wirklich so stimmt, weiß ich nicht. Aber es gibt tatsächlich
Geheimdienste, die sind so am Rand, am Limit, am Budget-Limit und die müssen sich halt auf bestimmte Kernaufgaben konzentrieren. Ist ja auch immer die Frage zwischen,
Inlandsgeheimdienst äh der Lindstaat vor inneren Feinden schützt unten im Auslandsgeheimdienst, also wenn du,
nur von Freunden umgeben bist und keinen Krieg führst und so, äh, dann brauchst du auch keinen Auslandsgeheimdienst,
wenn du irgend so ein Ministart,
der ohnehin schon wenig Ressourcen hat, dann kannst du halt schwer irgendwie,
den NAFDA Verhandlungen zu versuchen, mal die Amis abzuhören. Gegen hast du halt,
gegen Hallso halt keine Chance. Äh aber es gibt halt eben andere Staaten,
und erzählen nicht nur die dazu, äh, sondern insbesondere auch China, Russland, Iran, Israel und Sono, von denen haben wir halt keine Snowden. Die sagen halt ganz klar, wir haben hier einen riesen Komplex,
und die sind eben nicht nur dafür da, uns sicher zu hal,
sondern auch um uns wohlhabend zu halten, um uns äh gegen die anderen Nationen durchzusetzen.
Na ja.
Finde ich 'ne also wenn man dazu sagt dann ist das kann man das ja auch so machen.
Ja, das ist halt egoistisch, nationalistisch gedacht. Äh meine Nation zuerst äh,
ein bisschen wir sind im Jahr zwanzig siebzehn es wird quakrat alles schlimmer aber eigentlich könnte man sich auch mal zusammenreißen auf diesem Planeten und mal kollektiv versuchen voranzukommen.
Du meinst, es wäre doch schön, wenn alle einfach mal zusammenkommen würden und feststellen, wie schön,
Zusammenleben könnte. Wow, der Letzte, der das gesagt hat, wurde an dein Kreuz dafür genage.
Fuß mich jetzt gerade bei Jesus verglichen, du.
Nein, das würde ich doch niemals tun.
Na, der, also das, das warum ich das anspreche, ist also Israel wird hier natürlich nochmal was anderes dazu sagen, was Aufgabe ihres Geheimdienstes ist, ne? Und.
Hier haben wir ein ganz anderes Bedrohungs.
Haben an etwas anderes Bedrohungsszenario. Ähm.
Jetzt haben wir schon ein bisschen über die großen inhaltlichen äh Themen gesprochen. Jetzt ist dieser gesamte das gesamte Ding irgendwie drei Jahre gelaufen.
Was gab's denn mal, was könnte man denn jetzt als Erfolg dieses Ausschusses sehen? Also das, dass wir, dass man über diese Selektoren.
Praxis der Klarheit gefunden hat oder was heißt Klarheit, aber zumindest mal auf ein Problem aufmerksam wurde, was man vorher nicht kannte. Das ist auch sicherlich ein ähm ein Erfolg des,
Der der Ausschusstätigkeit. Ich glaube, das hat Peter Altmaier ja auch nochmal,
äh verteilt dieses Lob. Da haben sie sich auch alle gefreut.
Ja ähm na tatsächlich ist das so. Ähm.
Ausschuss hat herausgefunden, dass die absurden Rechtstheorien,
die der BND macht, dann auch endlich mal denjenigen, die dafür verantwortlich sind, das zu kontrollieren, bekannt sind? Aber die Konsequenz ist halt nicht, dass,
Die Praxis geändert wird, sondern dass das Gesetz geändert wird. Können wir gleich nochmal drauf eingehen mit einem neuen BND-Gesetz. Und die Praxis
Jetzt kann sich halt niemand mehr aussehen, zu wissen, was es Elektro ist, jetzt müssen halt die Verantwortlichen in den Kontrollgremien und äh im Kanzleramt selber,
eben auch in der interessierten Öffentlichkeit äh wissen halt so
grob wie diese technische Steam dahinter äh funktioniert und können sich nicht mehr,
rausreden der BND hat halt jetzt vierzigtausend NSA-Selektoren geprüft und fünfzehntausend eigene und damit angeblich,
Diese Freunde, die man da gefunden hat, nicht mehr überwacht. Ähm,
sagt jetzt, man überwacht jetzt keine Freunde mehr, nur nachprüfen kann's halt niemand, ne? Diese Elektrolisten sind halt nur vor einem BND, die kommen ja nicht mal im Kanzleramt an, geschweige denn bei irgendwelchen äh anderen Prüfgremien,
Wir also jetzt sagt uns der Geheimdienst, den wir mehrmals in Flankranti erwischt hat, Biagrech und Gesetz,
nee, jetzt ist, jetzt ist wirklich alles in Ordnung. Also jetzt bitte nicht nochmal nachfragen,
auf diesem Stand sind wir.
Gibt's irgendwelche ähm irgendwie eine Verbesserung der Kontrollsituation.
Äh es kommt drauf an, wenn du fragst, also wenn du eine große Koalition fragst, dann sagen die, die haben ja ähm ein,
Zusammenspiel mit dem BND-Gesetz auch das Kontrollgremiumsgesetz für das BKGR reformiert,
gibt's hier jetzt einen wie nennen sie das Sonderbevollmächtigten oder so und ein ständiges Ausschuss äh mit.
Die.
Aber gleichzeitig haben wir ein neues Kontrollgremium äh geschaffen. Ein viertes, was irgendwie äh auch noch nicht mal in Berlin angesiedelt wird. Also theoretisch wird das PKGR jetzt äh leicht, besser,
ausgestattet sein und sich nicht nur einmal im Monat zu treffen, sondern auch so ein Person zu haben, die da ständige Arbeit macht,
aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so schon angelaufen ist, ob die Person schon da ist, äh wann das losgeht und wie sich das dann in der Praxis auswirkt. An den grundsätzlichen Problemen, dass die zum Beispiel dieses Elektronisch lesen dürfen, ändert das wenig.
Und wir haben ja jetzt, wir haben ja nur das aufgearbeitet, was irgendwie in den Jahren
Zweitausenddrei bis zwanzig weiß ich nicht zwölf, dreizehn Wissnoten im Endeffekt rausgekommen ist,
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen aufgearbeitet und äh verbessert, aber das was in den letzten drei Jahren schon wieder passiert ist, ist kein Untersuchungsauftrag äh und das macht ja in der nächsten Untersuchungsausschuss in zehn Jahren, der das dann aufarbeiten kann, was jetzt passiert.
Ja, ich denke, man darf jetzt auch nicht zu viel an.
An diese Rolle des Untersuchungsausschusses als solches hängen. Ich meine, das war jetzt ähm für uns natürlich eine zentrale,
Ereignisfront an an der man sich vielleicht viel versprochen hat.
Ähm was man darüber dann äh skandalisieren, äh aufarbeiten, berichten kann. Das hat ja nun auch teilweise.
Gefunden. Vielleicht ist auch mehr dabei rausgekommen als man es,
hätte realistischerweise erwarten können, ist aber die Frage, wie realistisch sind die eigenen Erwartungen an der Stelle? Bisher waren Untersuchungsausschüsse im Geheimdienstbereich ja noch also soweit ich das überblicke. Ich überblicke das nicht gut, ne?
Neuland, ist absolutes.
Nein, es gab ja schon äh verschiedene Untersuchungsausschüsse äh so, aber das das jetzt alles äh,
die Dinge komplett geändert hätte äh kann ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so richtig dran erinnern. Also kein.
Sehen wir doch bei NSU, bei den ganzen NSU-Untersuchungsausschüssen,
danach gibt's äh Legalisierung von Vormännern äh und Ausbau von Verfassungsschutz.
Genau, also hier haben wir eher so ein grundsätzliches Problem und das ist äh wahrscheinlich eher so ein da erfordert äh also das das was wir uns jetzt hier vielleicht primär wünschen würden, erfordert halt einen grundsätzlichen,
Sinneswandel, der offensichtlich durch diese Maßnahmen, die wir jetzt äh gesehen und erkannt haben, nicht ausgelöst wird.
Ist die Frage, ob's überhaupt irgendein ähm Auslöser geben kann für einen solchen Sinneswandel? Woher denkst du, dass sie,
ist ja die Gesellschaft generell Immun. Gegen so ein äh Change so von.
Ja, wir brauchen da was, was, was, was im Geheimen agiert und uns beschützt.
Der Glaube ist halt irgendwie da, ne? Oder andersrum, der Glaube, dass das äh primär negativ ist, ist nicht da. Man nimmt wahrscheinlich dieses ganze negative irgendwie hin.
Denkt sich so, hm, na ja, vielleicht haben die da so ein paar Freiheiten, sehe ich ja in jedem James-Bond-Film und so,
Die liegen dann immer äh mit den Mädels auf der Yacht,
Aber sie sind ja, sie verhindern ja, dass dass die Bösen äh in ihrem unterirdischen Verließ mit großem äh Deckel auf der Vulkaninsel,
auf dem Knopf drücken und die Raketen starten lassen, ne? Ist nur äh Deepli imprinted.
Du wirst dich nochmal wundern, wie irgendein böser auf irgendeiner Vulkaninsel sitzt und und eine Rakete starten lässt. Ich glaube dem Thema sind wir e,
eher als uns allen lie.
Hawaii ist eine Vulkaninsel.
Ja, aber,
ist Face it, also das, das ist, das äh muss man vielleicht auch einfach mal ähm akzeptieren und und sich überlegen,
in inwiefern man da eine Diskussion vielleicht vorantreiben kann, jenseits dieses Hinterherrecherchierens et cetera
Also vielleicht geht's ja auch gar nicht.
Also wir hatten ja jetzt das Gelegenheitsfenster mal was zu ändern. Äh ich meine noch nie,
Nicht mal mit Echolon, aber noch nie war international die Debatte um was tun Auslandsgeheimdienste technisch, vor allem im Internetzeitalter so groß wie zwanzig, dreizehn mit den Snowdenenthüllungen,
da war ja Tabula Rasa Merkel Phone ging gar nicht,
Die deswegen gab's ja den Ausschuss über.
Eigentlich mal sagen muss, ne, also Angela Merkel ist halt ein Funktionsträger.
Genau.
Und der Funktionsträgertheorie entsprechend äh wo.
Wir ja auch, sind ja Grundrechtsträger, ist ja auch eine Funktion.
Die ähm.
Das das zittern aber nur, wenn sie nicht Deutsch spricht, äh aber sie hat auch gemeint, zu Recht in der Ausschusssitzung, dass es eigentlich nicht um ihr Handy ging, sondern um alle, das sehe ich auch so, mir ist ihr Scheiß in ihr Handy, scheißegal.
Genau das finde ich aber das war aber das war irgendwie das, was äh was richtig abgegangen ist, ne. Da haben dann irgendwie alle gesagt, oh was, wie dir.
Video hören alle ab. Wir hören alle ab. Auch Merkel.
Die die hören alle ab, okay. Aber auch Merkel. Das gibt's ja nicht. Ne, also das äh,
Das war wirklich auch äh absurd. Das ausgerechnet, dass ähm.
Dann irgendwie dem ganzen Thema nochmal eine richtig neue Welle gibt, ne.
Merkel Handy muss weg.
Ja, aber ähm damals vergab's halt das Gelegenheitsfenster äh mit Snowden, dass wir dieses Thema auf der Agenda hatten und wenn es irgendwann.
Eine Möglichkeit für Änderungen gegeben hätte, dann mit dieser Debatte, die da war, deswegen gab's ja diesen ganzen Ausschuss. Deswegen nehmen wir das ja äh so ernst und verfolgen das, auch wenn,
jetzt wieder nur äh so ein paar eingefleischte äh interessiert,
aber man muss halt auch so gesellschaftliche Realitäten da draußen anerkennen, so,
so gern wir in unsere Netzpolitik Nische sind und uns das beobachten und das für essenziell halten, weil das für uns elementarer Bestandteil von Demokratie und Zusammenleben äh ist,
sind halt die gesellschaftlichen Debatten da draußen ganz andere. Also das wird jetzt zum Bundestagswahlkampf, wird Geheimdienstüberwachung kein großes Thema und,
Ein Amri hat halt ein Snowden mal wieder übertönt,
Auf einmal ist die Deba,
wieder nee alles ganz wichtig, ist mir doch egal, ich hab nichts zu verbürgen, Hauptsache kein Terror und so,
So sind halt so sind halt die Debatten da draußen. Ist halt nur schade, ähm dass es halt bei den Geheimnissen, bei weitem nicht nur um Terror geht,
äh sondern vielmehr im Argen liegt und dass man Amri auch mit normalem,
Polizeiermittlungsarbeit eventuell hätte fassen können, aber es sind ja dann wieder Details, aber so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung ist das halt nur, ist das halt nur ein Bruchteil.
Unsere kleine Subkultur.
So unwichtig sind wir.
Wir haben noch ein, zwei Themen ausgelassen bisher, Drohnenkrieg.
Das ist jetzt aber äh zu distopisch äh um trotzdem nochmal um um trotzdem nochmal zu sagen, es ist unsere, es ist unsere Auf,
das Thema weiter in der öffentlichen Debatte zu halten, deswegen machen wir ja auch mit diesem Markus Spruch, deswegen sprechen wir immer noch von diesem ausgelutschten Thema, obwohl es äh
allen äh zu den Ohren rauskommt und niemand müsst sich so wirklich mehr damit interessiert, weil wir das eben für so wichtig halten. Deswegen hätten wir ja gerne, dass das Wahlkampfthema wird,
auch wenn wir nicht entscheiden, was Wahlkampf, äh, Thema wird, aber deswegen versuchen wir mit unseren Öffentlichkeiten das Thema
ja auf der Tagesordnung zu halten.
Trotzdem muss jetzt noch äh zu den zu den Ausschuss äh Ergebnissen zum Drohnenkrieg was sagen.
Ja, um den Drohnenkrieg ging's in dem Ausschuss,
eher am Rande. Also es waren glaube ich eine oder zwei Fragen äh von den einunddreißig Untersuchungsfragen ähm die der Untersuchungsausschuss ähm klären sollte.
Es gab ja den Zeugen Brandon Brand, äh Drohnen Operator äh,
im Deutschen gibt's ja kein schönes Wort dafür, dass äh leicht äh,
inakkurate Drohnenpilot ist trotzdem nicht komplett falsch,
Der hat halt da erzählt wie wichtig die Basis Ramstein ist. Nun hatte es ja schon ein paar Mal Thema gehabt und ich erzähle da jetzt nichts Neues, aber der hat halt gemeint, ohne Rammstein funktioniert der Drohnenkrieg der USA so nicht,
und jetzt ist halt die Frage erstens, was darf der Untersuchungsausschuss Ausschuss dazu rausfinden? Und da sagt die Bundesregierung eindeutig nichts,
es werden von dort keine Drohnen gesteuert und nur wenn sie darüber gesteuert würden, wäre das auch im Untersuchungsauftrag,
Opposition sieht das anders und meint die technische Weiterleitung der Signale ist auch eine Form von
darüber aber diese Rechtsdebatte hat die Opposition leider verloren und konnte da nicht wirklich mehr nach,
steht aber auch im Einklang,
restlichen.
Position der Bundesregierung zu dem Thema Ramstein,
Man hat zwei Jahre lang nachgebetet, was das weiße Haus vorgegeben hat mit wie drohenden Rammsteinen. Also es da starten keine und dort sitzt niemand, der die steuert und auch wenn immer alle gesagt haben, das ist aber nicht die Frage. Äh das haben wir gar nicht gefragt.
Was wurde was wird denn da drüber für Signale gerelat? Hieß immer, ja, das starten keine Drohne. Echt nicht,
Äh und das ist äh auch wenn man jetzt irgendwie mittlerweile davon abgedrück,
weil ein Diplomat in Deutschen dann gesagt hat, ja ja natürlich relaine wir das dort über die Satelliten ähm fragt mal eure Militärs, die wissen doch was so passiert.
Aber die Position der Bundesregierung ist immer noch die drei Affen in meinem Beitragsbild, nichts hören, nicht sehen,
was das andere nicht sagen, nichts riechen.
Ja, das ist also damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Äh Drohnenangriffe sind nicht per se völkerrechtswidrig,
Panzer und Flugzeuge kommen auch Leute um, genau wie bei Drohnen. Äh es ist halt immer die Frage, ob ein Zivilist umkommt oder ein Kompatant
und ob das rechtmäßig ist oder nicht oder so
geht's um jede Menge Detaildebatten, aber weder der Geheimdienstuntersuchungsausschuss noch,
parlamentarische Gremien, Verteidigungsausschuss, Parlamentarisch und Kontrollgremium, einzelne Abgeordnete, Fraktionen mit ihrem Fragerecht
der Bundesregierung irgendwas entlocken, was auch noch die in die Richtung geht von.
Stimmt, ihr habt Recht, das ist ein Skandal, wir fragen mal nach. Wir untersuchen das jetzt mal. Das will die Bundesregierung einfach nicht aus politischer,
Position, das ist ihre politische Entscheidung, dass sie das nicht wollen.
Scheint eh so eine politische Position zu sein, sich möglichst nicht mit den USA anzulegen, ne?
Also da das,
diese in der Anarchie der Geheimdienste im internationalen äh Gegeneinander, dass wir ja hier auch,
kritisierst, ähm ist natürlich auch klar, dass dass da Machtpositionen eine Rolle spielen und ähm
Dazu gehört eben, dass man gegenüber den USA einfach regelmäßig kneift.
Da fehlt einfach der Mut. Ich glaube, wenn wenn irgendwie keine Ahnung, Holland das gemacht hätte oder so, ähm dann hätte man sich da sicherlich berufen gefühlt, Stärke zu zeigen.
Und ähm genauso wie man sich ja offenbar auch,
viel stärker zu zeigen, wenn man andere Staaten ausspioniert, ja? da äh,
fühlt man sich irgendwie nicht berufen, sich mit großartig auseinanderzusetzen, aber wenn man dann irgendwie,
Opfer von US-Spionage ist, dann scheint es irgendwie Operton zu sein, möglichst,
sich am am besten noch nicht mal zu trauen, da etwas gegen zu tun, weil nachher sieht die USA knatschig.
Ja, noch schlimmer sind aber UK, äh Großbritannien ähm,
die bei den USA gab's immerhin äh musste sich auch Obama öffentlich einiges gefallen lassen und der war ja dann auch hier und er hat dazu gesichert, dass manche Akten endklassifiziert werden oder so, was nie passiert ist
hat sich bei Merkel zwar nicht entschuldigt, hat gemeint, wir werden uns nicht entschuldigen, dass wir besser sind als alle anderen,
aber ihr Handy wird jetzt so in Zukunft nicht mehr abgehört.
Was heißt bis gestern haben wir das gemacht.
Aber mit den USA gab's tatsächlich Konsultationsverfahren.
Um Akten, ob man die weitergeben kann oder so. Äh Großbritannien hat gemeint, wie ihr habt einen Untersuchungsausschuss, echt jetzt? Spinnt ihr?
Geheimdienste und Öffentlichkeit gehen nicht zusammen.
Euer Ausschuss ist doof und wir geben euch gar nichts null Nader. Und wenn irgendjemand von euch,
Boot Monkey Schulde, diese Operation, die wir da zu Snowdenzeiten gemeinsam machen wollten mit Glasfaser abgreifen,
in der Nordsee. Wenn das irgendjemand oder bei Frankfurt ist ja nicht so ganz klar, was es wurde. Wenn das irgendjemand erwähnt,
stellen wir die Zusammenarbeit mit euch komplett ein, ihr kriegt von uns keinen Hinweis auf den nächsten Terroranschlag und ihr habt dann die fünf politische Verantwortung, falls äh irgendwo eine Bombe in Deutschland hochgeht,
So hat Großbritannien argumentiert in dem Ausschuss. Ähm dass es nochmal eine Spur krasser äh als US.
In dem Ausschus.
Na ja, also.
Gegenüber der Regierung.
Ritischen Geheimnisvertreter haben das dem BND und dem Verfassungsschutz und dem äh Bundeskanzleramt gesagt,
Die haben das dem Ausschuss gesagt, also in nicht öffentlicher Sitzung, in einer dieser äh Beratungssitzungen und davon durfte aber kein Wort nach außen dringen, äh sonst ist.
Irgendwas offen. Äh sonst äh wird die Geheimniskooperation.
Woher weißt du das dann, wenn das so.
Weil's eben am nächsten Tag im Fokus stand,
mit Dingen, die da gar nicht besprochen wurden, um eben die These im Ausschuss ist, ähm um eben öffentlich äh das Bild zu zeichnen, dass der Ausschuss undicht ist äh
dass man dem nicht vertrauen darf äh und dass man den am besten gar nichts Geheimnis mehr geben sollte.
Stimmt, das war auch.
Kanzleramt, zumindest der Altmaier in den Ausschuss. Ey, hier viermal liegst einmal,
einmal Süddeutsche zweimal Netzpolitik org, was ist das überhaupt? Wenn sowas nochmal passiert, dann verklagen wir euch,
Altmaier ziemlich am Anfang von dem Ausschuss an den Untersuchungsausschuss äh gepostet. Ähm die These der Geheimdienste war,
Den Ausschuss kann man nicht trauen und wir sollten überhaupt gar keine öffentliche Kontrolle haben.
Das ist tatsächlich, also da ist tatsächlich ähm.
Also da da zeigt sich die Absurdität dieses Unterfangens, ne?
Also der einerseits ist der Ausschuss da, um Dinge zu untersuchen, dann sagen die, aber dann liegen die,
ja okay, das mag illegal sein, aber äh wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen, was wir da illegales tun, dann hört das auf und das wollen wir ja auch nicht. Ähm es ist schon wirklich ähm eine Absurdität, die diese Sitzung und wir haben ähm.
Und jetzt finde ich vorbildlich die ganze Zeit inhaltlich damit auseinandergesetzt, aber wir wollen vielleicht auch nochmal ganz kurz darüber sprechen, welche.
Also du hast zum Beispiel noch gar nicht über die Rolle der verschiedenen äh Parteien da gesprochen, ne? Also die die große Koalition hat natürlich irgendwie andere
andere Anreize in diesem Ausschuss als die Opposition und ist meins, es zeigt sich an so vielen interessanten Konflik
die der die der Ausschuss über seine Zeit hatte äh wie die Ausweitung des Untersuchungsauftrags, das Laden von,
Noten als Zeugen, äh wie da irgendwie immer wieder so ein äh
so ein Hütchenspiel stattgefunden hat. Wie wie bewertest du das denn.
Tja, es ist ähm eine Politik, dieser Ausschuss ist ja ein,
Mini Abbild des Bundestages an sich äh so wie die Sitzverteilung im Bundestag ist äh ist in.
Total reduziert, äh auch die Sitzverteilungen im Ausschuss. Also die Union haben vier,
Abgeordnete da drin, die SPD zwei und Linke und Grüne je ein,
als Opposition? Plus, dann haben die nochmal Stellvertreter,
Ähm aber
also genau wie die äh große Koalition auch im Plenum eine fast achtzig Prozentige Mehrheit hat und da halt Gesetze ohne großartige Wiederrede durchpeitschen kann
Kunden, die auch viele, viele Dinge in dem Ausschuss einfach so beschließen gegen die Opposition statt gemeinsam am Anfang einige Dinge hat man gemeinsam beschlossen, aber oft,
Öfters mal gab's auch einen richtigen Konflikt zwischen Regierung und Opposition.
Die einzelnen Parteien sind natürlich alle unterschiedlich, auch die einzelnen Abgeordneten sind alle unterschiedlich, aber.
Mal abgesehen von Patrick Sensburg, der ja auch von der Union ist, der aber Vorsitzender ist und der eine echt ja, wie soll man das beschreiben? Echt,
Wo jede Rolle hatte, so gleichzeitig Vorsitzender, aber auch CDU-Meinungen, Reservistenverband äh kritisiert Merkel auch gerne mal von rechts so mit den Flüchtlingen, das geht ja gar nicht,
Ist aber so eher manchmal der so verständnisvolle Opa im Ausschuss, also so Kop hinter uns ging gar nicht und so und,
war ja dann auch fast per du ähm den Freunden, aber inhaltlich
Ähm, also in offener Sitzung hat er sich manchmal mit den ein oder anderen Abgeordneten der anderen Fraktion inklusive der SPD,
gebettelt, äh wie man hört, soll das hinter verschlossenen Tür, also manchmal richtiges Schrei,
ähm Kinderauseinandersetzung gewesen, sei inzwischen mehreren, aber unter anderem auch Patrick Sensburg, also er hat viele Gesichter da,
Mehrere der Unionsabgeordneten, also das war so immer der Running Gag äh für die Leute, die äh den Ausschuss,
wenn die Union anfängt Fragen zu stellen, dann kann man Kaffee holen oder wird's uninteressant.
Die lesen nur vor, was vorherige Zeugen äh gefragt haben,
Manche Abgeordnete wie äh Schipanski, deren Rolle ist es eigentlich nur zu sagen, dass,
BND und Bundesregierung Recht haben, dass das alles gar nicht so schlimm ist und dass man die Überwachung braucht. Ich glaube, das ist auch der einzige, der den Satz ausspendet unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht nicht unterschreiben würde, weil der meint, doch, doch, das müssen wir weiterhin gehen
weil der eben mein Deutschland überall ist und man muss sich halt international ähm durchsetzen,
Ähm und andere haben dann eher langweilige Fragen gestellt, aber manchmal tue ich es auch interessante Fragen, also auch ähm.
Haben halt nur nicht alle dann intensiv zugehört. SPD ist zwielichtig, ist in der großen Koalition und gerade,
Herr Fliesig, ähm,
manchmal echt ganz schön Energie an den Tag gelegt, also manche der Themen, Winos,
Abkommen und so, da hat da wirklich was dran gefressen und war da hinterher,
ging aber eben auch um den Wahlkampf um eben,
CDU eins mitzugeben, aber man war ja die drei, vier Jahre lang jetzt gemeinsam in der Regierung,
manchmal sehr deutlich geworden in Bewertungen, äh politischen Bewertungen, aber auch gegenüber ähm Kanzleramtsministern oder ähm gegen Ministern äh von Sozen. Ähm
in der öffentlichen Debatte und es sich sicher gut Fehler erkannt und gute Verbesserungsvorschläge zu machen. Äh,
Ist dann aber im Endeffekt doch ein Abgeordneter der großen Koalition, können wir gleich nochmal drauf über die Rolle von Snowden zum Beisp,
auch er möchte nicht, dass äh jetzt endlich eine Einladung ins Noten ausgesprochen wird, damit der kommt,
Obwohl er sagt, ich würde ihn ja schon gern hören. Und die Grünen und die L.
Er das? Wie wie begründet er das.
Ach, das ist, das können wir gleich nochmal drauf eingehen, dass es eine äh längliche und sehr obskure Debatte. Linke und Grüne haben jeweils nur einen Abgeordneten äh als Obperson und dann einen Stellvertreter.
Aber das heißt, das sind ja hier wird also von Linke und Grüne saßen da denke ich immer Andre Hahn und Martina Renner von der Linken und äh Konstantin von Nortz.
Und Hans-Christian Ströbele von den Grünen. Die saßen aber auch gleichzeitig dort.
Ja da,
Personen und Stellvertreter. Äh die haben Stellvertreter. Äh die dürfen auch dazu sammeln hingehen. Nur in der Routinearbeit äh hat halt einer den Hut auf,
in den Obleute treffen, kommt halt immer nur einer von jeder Fraktion in die,
Treptow-Verfahren in wo die Dokumente im Kanzleramt oder im BND sind,
dass nur die Obleute lesen und nicht die Stellvertreter die,
ob Leute haben die internen Runden, die ob Leute haben die politische,
Verantwortlichkeit und die Stellvertreter, die unterstützen,
sie, aber meistens sind auch die Mitarbeiter von den Obleuten und dann von den Fraktionen mit den Obleuten am meisten in Kontakt und nicht auch noch mit den Stellvertretern. Aber ja
die nur eine Person gehabt, dann hätten wir das ja gar nicht leistbar gewesen, schon so ähm haben irgendwie jeweils anderthalb Abgeordnete, also zwei Abgeordnete,
plus ein Mitarbeiter vom Abgeordnetenbüro plus,
Mitarbeiterinnen der Fraktion oder ein Mitarbeiter der Fraktion
die die ganze Ausschussarbeit machen sollen. Also alle Akten lesen, diese ganzen was,
hier für eine lustige Zahl dreitausend, ne zweitausendvierhundert Aktenordner.
Diese Millionen an Dokumente,
das sollte theoretisch alles gelesen werden. Ich bezweifle, dass das irgendjemand geschafft hat. Die müssen sich dann auch Strategien und überlegen durchsuchbar machen und gucken was welche,
Teile man wie am besten bearbeitet und so. Bei Union, die haben dann halt gleich mal fünf bis zehn Leute da,
das tatsächlich äh alles machen, aber die äh Opposition halt nicht.
Aber selbst wenn's fünf bis zehn Leuten brauchst du noch lange, um das alles zu schredder.
Ja, das, das Schreddern, mehr der Geheimdienste, nicht vom Ausschuss, aber,
das ist das ist viel Holz und dann müssen die Sitzungen vorbereitet werden, die Fragen gestellt werden, Presseanfragen und Veranstaltungen nebenbei gemacht werden und so. Und dann sind die auch noch normale Abgeordnete in anderen Ausschüssen. Die sind ja dann trotzdem noch äh
in der Fraktion und im Plenum und in dem Sportausschuss oder einem Beef Ströbele im,
Kontrollgremium und so weiter und so fort. Die machen ja den drei Jahre lang nicht vierundzwanzig sieben nur diesen Ausschuss.
Das eine Mordsarbeit.
Das ist eine Mordsarbeit, aber habe äh.
Bin ich auch wirklich beeindruckt von davon, dass sie das ausgehalten haben. Sowohl die die.
Ähm äh Abgeordneten selber als auch deren Mitarbeiter. Das ist äh also ich glaube, ich werde da irgendwann durchgedreht.
Was ist denn jetzt, wann ist denn mit dem Ergebnis mit dem Abschlussbericht zu rechnen.
Also der Ausschuss macht das Ganze ja nicht, damit wir bloggen können.
Sondern damit der Papier produziert, einen
Bundestagsdrucksachen, ein Bericht und jetzt mit dem Ende der Zeugenvernehmungen, mit dem sogenannten Ende der Beweisaufnahme, Beweisaufnahme war ja
Wir lassen uns Dokumente zukommen, Akten, die wir durchlesen und wir hören Zeugen an, die haben das ja beides als Informationsquelle, nur die Öffentlichkeit hat ja nur die Zeugen und das, was auf Wiki Leaks gelandet ist.
Und jetzt nehmen die eben diese ganzen Informationen, die die gesammelt haben und verarbeiten die zu einem großen Bericht,
äh so wie ich höre, auch in zwei Teilen. Die eine Hälfte ist eine Sammlung an Fakten. Was haben wir denn herausgefunden, was ist denn passiert, was,
passiert denn,
und dann neben dem zweiten Teil eine politisch juristisch sachliche Bewertung. Wie bewerten wir das? Und welche, das ist ja der eigentliche äh Ziel davon, welche Konsequenzen ziehen wir jetzt daraus? Wie schützen wir uns zur Kommunikation jetzt besser, vor Geheimdienstüberwachung oder so,
oder wie machen wir das jetzt, dass der BND nicht mehr illegal agiert, sondern legal.
Das führt natürlich dann ganz interessant äh werden, was da für Vorschläge kommt.
Ja, die Frage ist, ich frage mich schon, wie viele Leute, die mehreren tausend Seiten äh dann lesen werden. Äh ja, genau, danke.
Na du doch.
Das hast du den Job.
Das passiert jetzt, das wird,
und das muss, wie ich höre, in den nächsten zwei zweieinhalb Monaten geschehen, denn.
Ich glaub ab Juni ist parlamentarische Sommerpause.
Danach ist Wahlkampf. Äh also auch jetzt gibt ja der Wahlkampf schon los, aber das heißt in der letzten also noch vor der Sommerpause muss der Abschlussbericht im Plenum vom gesamten Bundestag angenommen werden.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Untersuchungsausschüsse, NSU gab's, ähm, Abgasaffäre gibt's, Comacs gibt's und so und die,
werden auch ihren Abschlussberuf vorstellen, der muss auch vom Plenum angenommen werden. Und da gibt's noch äh Battle, wann, welcher Abschlus,
äh welche Sitzungswoche bekommt und wahrscheinlich kriegt er von diesem Untersuchungsausschuss die vorletzte
und das ist quasi schon Anfang Juni,
so und das heißt bis Ende Mai muss das Ding eigentlich stehen. Äh damit.
Ähm, das hat Ausschusssekretariat die haben sich jetzt extra nochmal, das sind die,
die die ganzen Beweisverschlüsse der äh
ob Leute und des Ausschusses angenommen haben und dann zu den ganzen Ministerien und Behörden gegangen sind, haben gesagt, wir haben hier ähm Beweisbeschluss und Untersuchungsausschuss, ihr müsst euch uns mal die Akten geben, die dann die Aktenordner annimmt, manche Dinge scannen, das dann verteilen, die die Zeugen einladen, die die Räume buchen und so, die die ganze Orga-Arbeit machen,
das so 'n Einheit von Bundestag an sich über fraktionell,
Die haben sich ein paar Juristen angestellt, wie ich höre, die zumindest diese Sachbeschreibung,
Schreiben von den Fakten, das passiert ist,
und dann höchstwahrscheinlich, so wie ich das sehe, höre, schreiben die diversen,
unen jeweils eine eigene rechtliche Bewertung,
was davon zu halten ist. Also die Mitarbeiterstäbe,
die sind von Union und SPD eher größer, die machen dann aber auch die anderen Untersuchungsausschüsse und dann halt beim Ausschuss am,
Bekanntesten dürfte wahrscheinlich äh Anne Roth von der Linksfraktion sein, als Mitarbeiterin der Linksfraktion und äh Stefan Martin äh als Mitarbeiterin von äh.
Ähm Martina Renner und eben bei Konstantin von Notz, wie,
die Fraktion, also jeweils so, die haben sie dann noch,
Praktis, die suchen sowie ich höre auch noch Leute, die damit helfen oder so, falls irgendjemand bemüsigt fühlt,
die schreiben also die Opposition sind so jeweils drei, vier Leute plus Abgeordnete mit ihrem riesen Tagespensum, die das jetzt,
abrackern dürfen in zwei Monaten dieses ganze Ding zu verschriftlichen,
mal überlegt, wie lange jemand für so eine Bachelorarbeit an der Uni hat.
Kann man jetzt mal so eine Diste zwei Monaten runterreißen oder so. Das ist schon oben. Das ist schon ordentlich Holz.
Ist mega krass, vor allem wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie viele Leute sich das dann danach wirklich durchlesen werden.
Alle, die wichtig sind, zumindest in der Theorie. Ja, in der.
Es ist jeder, der da mal Zeuge war, wird sicherlich nachblättern, was dann sozusagen von,
ihnen da geblieben ist und äh sicherlich muss irgendeine äh arme Kreatur bei einem der Dienste sich das,
durchlesen und äh ein Management Samery machen, aber ansonsten ist ja nun gerade von einer scheidenden Regierung äh da entscheidenden Parlament nicht unbedingt davon auszugehen, dass man sich dann primär erstmal auf die Konsequenzen von so einem
Untersuchungsaustausch Ausschuss stürzt, zumal
Nach der Wahl ist hier alles erstmal wieder anders und was äh kümmert mich das Geschrei von gestern? Von daher muss man grundsätzlich natürlich an diesem Konzept des Untersuchungsausschusses, so wie er derzeit existiert. Also,
gebunden an äh so eine Parlaments ähm Legislatur, muss man halt dran zweifeln.
Na ja, es gab ja auch Untersuchungsausschüsse, die sind eher fertig geworden. Äh in,
war, glaube ich, ziemlich schnell fertig, wenn ich jetzt nicht lüge im Bundestag
Ähm und es gab ja jetzt trotzdem auch,
schon 'ne Gesetzesänderung, obwohl der Ausschuss noch gar nicht fertig ist, was,
gut oder schlecht sehen kann, je nachdem, aber eigentlich wird der Bericht ja jetzt geschrieben, damit die nächste Bundesregierung das dann alles umsetzen kann.
Wenn es denn passiert oder so, je nach Wahlausgang. Aber wir haben da, ich mein,
Also ganz ehrlich, wie viele von euch haben den Abschlussbericht der Enquete-Kommission Internet in digitaler Gesellschaft gelesen und wie viele Gesetze sind nach den vier Jahren Arbeit und jede Menge Totenbaum, der da produziert wurde, dann Gesetze geworden,
das ist halt das
Es ist eine Perspektive. Ich meine ähm ohne, dass ich nachgeguck,
Einschätzung ist das auch, dass es ziemlich wenig ist, aber ich glaube in manchen Bundestagsreden hat man sich dann damals äh darauf bezogen, wie wir ja schon in der Enquete-Kommission festgestellt haben und so.
Das war.
Glaube, dass es ja die größte Ehre.
Das ist eine super Formulierung, da kann man alles behaup.
Ja, genau.
Wie ja schon im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss diskutiert wurde.
Genau im PDF auf Seite sechshundertdreiundachtzig.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch, glaube ich, als letztes Thema Snowden widmen,
der derjenige aufgrund dessen, dass alles stattgefunden hat, für den wir das alles gemacht haben.
Sollte zwar als Zeuge geladen werden, aber nicht von also wie war's nun mal?
Alle, der Ausschuss hat Unisono entschieden, wir wollen den als Norden hören, hat sich dann aber sehr, sehr schnell darin zerstritten, ähm wo und unter welchen Bedingungen und wie man ihn hören wolle, oder?
Genau, äh der Ausschuss hat den äh Zeugen beschlossen. Ähm es wird beweis erhoben zum Untersuchungsantrag durch Vernehmung von Edwards Noten als Zeugen,
Achter Mai vierzehn in einer der ersten äh Sitzungen das haben. Äh.
Opposition und Regierungsfraktionen alle gemeinsam.
Macht ja auch Sinn, ne? Ohne den hätte es den ganzen Ausschuss nicht gegeben.
Und dann war die Frage, ja, wie machen wir denn das jetzt? Ähm und der war, darf's eine ziemlich einfache Antwort,
schicken ihm halt ein Flugzeug und fliegen den hierher und setzen den in den Ausschuss und dann äh hören wir dem vierundzwanzig Stunden zu und landen den nochmal ein, weil das so viel interessant ist, äh zu,
erzählen hat. Und da hat aber die Bundesregierung gemeint echt, sieht ein Flugzeug setzen oder auf deutschen Boden holen, das ist glaube ich nicht.
Und dann in das in das Hotel Adlon zwischen UK zwischen die Botschaft der Amerikaner und den Briten.
Der Amerikaner aus der Bericht. Das wird doch abgefangen, das Flugzeug, das muss so äh zwischenlanden. Ähm ja, dann ging die Frage los.
Kann man den auf deutschen Boden lassen? Ähm dann hat man mal das Justizministerium gefragt,
Ja, wir haben ja gehört, irgendwie in der Zeitung gelesen, in Amerika gibt's irgendeine Untersuchung, die bereiten Anklage gegen ihn vor. Es gibt da Ermittlungen,
weiß manen, was ihm da droht und während das Asylgründe in Deutschland ähm,
und seitdem untersucht das Justizministerium so seit über zwei Jahren, so seit ungefähr drei Jahren ähm die juristische Lage, was denn passieren würde, wenn Deutschland,
ähm äh wenn dann Snoten auf deutschem Boden landen würde. Leider.
Als Asylgründer andererseits Abschiebegrün. Auslieferungsgründe, ne?
Ja, als Ausländer, ne? Darf jetzt nicht mehr rein. Nee, es ging das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge. Also das eine ist, was ihm denn passieren äh würde bei einer Auslieferung,
und ob er ausgeliefert werden müsste, also einfach nur das ähm was der Ausschuss braucht,
Und da das dauert leider seine Zeit, dass Justizministerium hatte, also es war bestimmt
die besten Referenten drangesetzt, aber die sind leider in den drei Jahren noch nicht zu einem Ergebnis gekommen und die werden sicherlich also dann so a,
Juni oder so, wenn der Ausschussbericht dann abgenommen ist und der Ausschuss vorbei ist, dann werden sie sicherlich auch mal irgendwo ein Statement abgeben. Äh aber sie konnten sich vorher leider dazu nicht durchringen.
Und das ist doch dann wirklich eine Farce, ne? Also dass das zu prüfen,
wird nicht lange dauern, ne? Wenn man das wirklich jetzt mal juristisch vernünf,
prüfen wollen würde, dann könnte man das tun und dann könnte man am Ende sagen OK hier und da ist unser Handlungsspielraum und da müssen wir uns eben hinstellen und sagen Arsch lecken ähm,
Wir hören ihn jetzt an und wir liefern den nicht aus, sondern wir geben dem sicheres Geleit nach äh Russland und alles ist gut und das wäre ähm.
Das einzige was das wäre ist ein diplomatischer Ekla.
Den möchte die Bundesregierung natürlich verhindern,
das ist alles um das es hier geht, ne? Also man äh ich finde das gut, dass du das so so schönes Schild hast wie,
wie wie man sowas dann eben realbürokratisch
umsetzt, aber die Tatsache ist ganz einfach, dass das
kein Regierungsmitglied insbesondere natürlich Angela Merkel und der Chef BK ähm.
Alle anderen, ich auch, Jusi, zumindest eine Maß nicht, also könnte auch die SPD nicht rauslassen, der ist dafür verantwortlich.
Also kein kein dass niemand der in der niemand niemand der in der Regierung ist,
möchte sich diesen diesen Diplomatischen Fallort geben.
Das ist eine politische Entscheidung,
Und die Verantwortlichen Regierungen äh die verantwortliche Regierung, Minister haben entschieden, wir wollen ihn hier nicht, wir spielen auf Zeit,
Wir lassen's loben, nicht deutschen Boden betreten. Das ist die einzige Antwort, warum er nicht hier ist,
dann in den Nebensatz dann fürchten sich, wenn er schon einmal hier wäre, könnte er einen Asylantrag stellen, was er ja in Russland in der Botschaft nicht darf, weil man kann ja nicht in Botschaften äh einen Asylantrag stellen. Deswegen muss man erstmal illegal einreisen, damit man das dann hier tun kann,
Und so, dass es dann das nächste diplomatische Thema, ob er hier eventuell sogar Asylgründe hätte. Nee, ist aber,
geht nur darum, man will ihn gar nicht erst auf deutschem Boden haben,
weil angeblich geht das international nicht.
Eins abgesehen davon, wenn hier aus der Türkei einreist und da nicht mehr zurückwillen, dann kann er auch erstmal bleiben oder Agenten irgendwie aus Iran oder so oder Nordkorea, kein Problem. Da ist der kurze Dienstweg,
Aber bei Snowden ist die Ansage politisch nee, das gibt Ärger mit Obama und jetzt halt mit seinem Nachfolger.
Mit dem wir zu euch keinen Ärger.
Veruneiner twittert der.
Ja, wobei äh ich weiß nicht, ob es sich demnächst zum guten Ton gehört äh also wenn man keinen Ärger mit Trump hat, ob das also nicht schon wieder ein Problem ist. Also in gewisser Hinsicht äh sich die Zeit äh da auch gewandelt.
Ja, aber das ist peinlich, also ohne diesen Typen,
Wüssten wir nichts ohne diesen Typen hätten wir nicht ein halbes Jahr lang, hätte nicht Lobo ein Jahr lang auf Sponder rüber geschrieben, äh mal ganz abgesehen von uns, ohne diesen Typen hätten wir den Untersuchungsausschuss nicht gehabt. Das ist ja nun auch der einzige weltweit ist in dem Parla.
Ging ja nicht darum, es ging ja darum, was was ist, was ist sozusagen die Konsequenz, wenn der Asyl beantragt war, das tut er natürlich dann,
und äh mit der Frage wollten sie sich einfach nicht beschäftigen.
Auch wenn das vielleicht ganz äh äh klug gewesen wäre, ihn äh in Deutschland vorzuhalten als ausgerechnet in Moskau.
Stattdessen kommt Verfassungsschutzpräsident Maaßen in den Ausschuss und meint, ja, der ist ja wohl russischer Agent, oder? So äh sonst könnte der ja nicht so lange da bleiben und hat nicht nur er gesagt. Und jetzt abgesehen davon vor zwei, drei Wochen oder so, war irgendein.
Ja aber wer das nicht auch super in russischen Agenten mal äh habhaft zu werden, also es müsste ihn doch eigentlich sehr.
Schnappt ihn euch.
Haben sie doch auch zwei gefunden, dieses Pärchen da irgendwo in Südwestdeutschland vor zwei, drei Jahren oder so.
Aber gleichzeitig gab's dann vor zwei, drei Wochen so eine Meldung, dass äh Putin oder der Kreml überlegt, ihn als äh Gast, als äh Präsent,
Snowden an Trump zu übergeben als Aufta,
guten Beziehungen oder so. Äh ja, die These.
Dann wird's aber richtig blutig für die deutsche Regierung.
Dass ähm.
Eher russischer Agent ist, also natürlich habe ich auch keine Fakten, aber ich glaube, das erscheint mir noch ziemlich weit hergeholt, vor allem, wenn man wie Maaßen keine weiteren Fakten hat, als das, was öffentlich bekannt ist. Äh und man hätte ihn ja auch hier anhören können.
Ja, er wäre ja auch nicht in Moskau so blieben, wenn die USA nicht ihren seinen Pass zurückgezogen hätten, also.
Fangen doch nicht an mit Fakten.
Könnte mir bei Putin eher vorstellen, dass er sagt, möchtest du unseren Erkenntnissen zurückkamen, dann hätten wir aber auch ein paar von unseren gerne zurück.
Na ja, das wird auf jeden Fall ein gefangenes Austausch. Da werden die ist eh schon wieder kalter Krieg angesagt, dann kann man das ja auch gleich so machen.
Nee, aber das ist echt peinlich. Also der ganze Ausschuss für mich ähm
endet echt in Peinlichkeit, dass sie's nicht schaffen, den Snowden anzuhören,
Dann gibt's immer die Ausrede der Regierung und da könnte ja auch eine Videokonferenz machen,
stimmt nicht, ähm weil dann kann er ja nicht offen und frei aussagen. Er theoretisch ist er in seinem Asyl in Russland auch daran gebunden, sich nicht zu weit politisch aus dem Fenster zu lehnen,
und wenn ihr dann wirklich mal auspackt, ähm, dann kann er das da nicht halt auch den
Anwalt Wolfgang Karlek, einen Brief an den Ausschuss geschrieben, den wir veröffentlicht haben, kann man das alles nachlesen, kann der Ausschuss wissen,
wenn er denn möchte, aber es ist eine politische Entscheidung.
Ist ja schön, dass wir jetzt rausgefunden haben, dass wir irgendwas mit den Selektonen nicht gestimmt hat und dass wir das Recht an die Geheimdienste anpassen müssen. Aber das mit dem Snowden, das wäre dann auch zu viel des Guten.
Ne, ich freue mich, was die amerikanische äh Regierung alles so an die Deutsche herangetragen hat für den Fall, dass.
Ich ich stelle mir irgendwie so vor wie Edwards Norden im NS Auer verhört wird und dann,
von Marian Wendt gefragt wird,
was, welche Grundrechte müssen wir noch alle aufgeben, um uns noch besser zu schützen vor dem Terror, ersten Oden.
Das hätte ich mir, das hätte ich gerne gesehen.
Oh weia.
Deswegen kommst du zu einem Fazit über den Ausschuss, dass äh von Konstantin Notz als deutlich zu negativ und defetistisch bezeichnet wurde. Auf Twitter. Ähm fasse das doch mal zusammen.
Mein Fazit. Ich bin jetzt die letzte Absatz vorlesen von dem Kommentar, aber das ist ja ein bisschen langweilig aus Internet vorzulesen. Na, das ist also schon allein diesen sich nicht.
Zu trauen, diesen Snowden anzuhören. Ich meine, das liegt nicht nur nicht nur,
Ausschuss, sondern auch in der Bundesregierung, aber die sechs Abgeordneten der Regierungsparteien inklusive Christian Fliesig,
weigern sich einen Zeugen, Einladung äh zu beschließen als Ausschuss,
der der den die Regierung dann umsetzen muss,
schon allein die Abgeordneten der großen Koalition in dem Ausschuss,
ziehen den Schwanz ein und wollen einfach gar nicht erst ihre Regierung in Bedrängnis äh bringen ähm dann irgendwie eine Entscheidung herbeiführen zu müssen. Und das finde ich feige und peinlich,
für den Ausschuss. Eigentlich ist er angetreten, das, was Noten der ganzen Welt enthüllt hat, nämlich, dass unsere,
digitale Welt komplett überwacht wird, ähm drunter kann man's eigentlich äh kaum sagen, auch wenn viele das anders sehen.
Ähm, aber den kann ich dann nochmal empfehlen, die ganzen Snowdenmeldungen tatsächlich nochmal zu lesen,
übrigens nie dementiert wurden.
Ähm der Ausschuss ist angetreten, das aufzuklären,
Das hat er nicht geschafft, die Überwachung geht weiter.
Äh
Unter Abteilungsleiter oder so, ein BND hat sein Posten verloren, Schindler hat seinen Posten verloren, hat einen neuen, gibt einen neuen DBD-Präsident, aber offiziell hat das damit gar nichts zu tun, äh weil wir sagen überhaupt keine Gründe, warum das so passiert ist.
Und wir wissen im Endeffekt gar nicht allzu viel mehr über die Snowdenenthüllungen als vorher,
wir wissen es, dass der BND selber Recht und Gesetz gebrochen hat, dass der BND selber Freunde abgehört hat,
Aber das hat jetzt ein Gesetz alles legalisiert und angeblich macht der BND das jetzt nicht mehr, aber alles was der BND vorher illegal war die ganzen,
komische Theorien, die er sich ausdenken musste, das wurde jetzt im neuen Gesetz geändert und jetzt darf der BND auch im Inland und vielmehr und ohne irgendwelche Limits abhören,
und seine einzige Begrenzung ist das Geld, wovon er auch zwei Drittel mehr bekommen hat als im Snotenjahr. Ich finde das peinlich.
Ciao. Beim anderen Fazit habe ich jetzt auch gar nicht gerechnet.
Aber ich kann ja noch hinzufügen.
Jetzt noch den positiven Ausblick.
Genau, das ist mein Fazit.
Dieses Ausschusses,
müssen wir uns ja nicht zufrieden geben. Das ist ja, was unsere gewählten Abgeordneten mit unserem Mandat jetzt herausgefunden haben in diesen drei, vier Jahren, aber Gesellschaft sind ja nicht nur die,
sondern auch wir, deswegen werden wir ja nicht müde äh über diese Themen weiter zu bericht,
das wichtig zu finden und so Maul aufzumachen,
und auch wenn's nicht Wahlkampfthema Nummer eins sein wird, ähm! Die, das kommt ja nicht von ungefähr.
SPD und CDU sind dafür verantwortlich. Kann man fragen, kann man überlegen, ob man die wählen möchte.
Andere Parteien mit ihren anderen Positionen. Es gibt ja diverse da draußen, aber wir entscheiden das,
unter anderem mit unserer Wahl und.
Mit unseren Abgeordneten, zu dem wir noch nie hingegangen sind und denen mal die Meinung gesagt hat,
auf ich, weil meiner ist Ströbele. Äh aber.
Wir waren unterzeugender.
Die haben ja alle Sprechstunden. Äh man könnte ja da mal hingehen und die mal denen mal sagen, ey, es ist zwar drei Jahre später, aber ich finde das immer noch wichtig. Aber wenn das niemand tut, äh dann passiert's halt nicht. Und,
können dagegen klagen. Also hab ja die GF mitgegründet mit Ulf um eben,
so ist für TG Gladigation, dass man auf einem professionelleren Level nochmal neu anzugehen und,
unter anderem mit ein paar Erkenntnissen aus diesem Ausschuss,
kann man jetzt halt auch viel besser gerichtlich vorgehen. Vorhalt, vorher war halt immer so die Frage, weiß ja auch nicht so ganz genau, was der BNL da so macht. Jetzt wissen wir halt so ein paar,
ein paar Funktionsmechanismen
und jetzt kann man halt gegen neue gesetzliche Regelungen, wie gegen das neue G zehn Gesetz, was ja auch vor anderthalb Jahren geändert wurde, gegen das neue BND Gesetz und so besser klagen, weil man mehr,
Hintergrundinformationen hat und das besser begründen kann. Was dann natürlich die Justiz entscheidet, ist wieder der nächste Punkt.
Kleine Frage noch hinterher. Ähm,
mediale Begleitung so aus Szene war ja im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen was No und so ein Novum, also einerseits natürlich die angesprochene Protokolle, dann gab's noch den äh,
dazu. Also man,
Kann jetzt auch nicht behaupten, es hätte jetzt keine Anstrengung äh gegeben. Was ist denn so dein Eindruck,
Wie das gewirkt hat, beziehungsweise was man daraus ähm vielleicht lernen äh und noch besser machen kann, sollte eine,
eine in der nahen Zukunft eine eine ähnliche Fokussierung auf so ein Thema in irgendeiner Form wieder anstehen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das äh in dieser Form so wiederkommt, das war schon ein ziemlich äh einmalige Gelegenheit ähm wir waren ja vorher schon bei Netzpolitik manchmal in Ausschüssen und haben halt verschiedene Anhörungen zu Sachverständigenthemen äh
protokoliert und so, aber so ein Untersuchungsausschuss funktioniert halt echt ganz anders als so ein ständiger Ausschuss, der an dem Gesetzentwurf,
berät, der hat viel mehr Möglichkeiten und die Zeugen waren ja alle,
zumindest für uns nur jetzt spannend. Ähm,
wir haben das halt so begleitet, dass wir das von,
uns von Anfang an klar, aber wir gehen dahin, machen einen Live-Blog und irgendwann hat sich herauskritisiert, scheiße, jetzt müssen wir das jedes Mal machen und das sind zwei ja nicht abzusehen, wie viele fünfzig hundert Sitzungen. Es wurden dann sechsundsechzig und wir haben's dann auch durchgezogen,
ganz so klar war als das von Anfang an auch nicht, aber wir fanden das die richtige Reaktion.
Aber es gab sicherlich zwischendurch auch mal den Moment, wo ihr euch einfach nur gedacht habt, so Scheiße.
Ja, ich war ja dann auch mal ein halbes Jahr im Urlaub und dann hat Ana das übernommen und das war dann in der Rückblende auch ganz okay. Das jetzt mal irgendwie so ein bisschen aufzuteilen und nicht jedes einzelne Mal äh machen zu müssen,
Die Podcast-Jungs äh waren ganz cool, dass die irgendwann mit dazu kommen. Äh,
scheint ja auch von den äh höhere Zahlen äh ganz gut angenommen worden zu sein, ist übrigens Vorbild,
es gibt 'n Untersuchungs, es gibt 'n weiteren Podcast, nach Vorbild von technischer Aufklärung,
Gesprächsaufklärung und geht um den NSU-Ausschuss in Brandenburg.
Auch ganz cool, dass technische Aufklärung das irgendwie geschafft hat, um eben das weiter zu verbreiten. Gerade die NSU-Leute, die haben ja,
NSU-Watch, NSU, Leaks, äh, diese Prozessbeobachtung und so, da gibt's ja in fünf Bundesstaaten Untersuchungsausschüsse und jetzt gab's schon den zweiten auf Bundesebene und so, da passiert noch viel mehr,
als in unserer Szene, nur haben wir das halt nicht so ganz auf dem Schirm, äh weil das halt nicht unser Kern äh Politik ist,
aber da haben wir unter anderem uns an denen so ein bisschen ein Beispiel genommen, dass tatsächlich auch,
zu ziehen und dann manche aus der NSU-Politik eben auch auf das geschielt und das als,
Inspiration genommen, was wir da so gemacht haben. Das ist schon ganz cool, das hat bei uns ganz,
net funktioniert nur irgendwann hatten wir zum Beispiel Netzpolitik nicht mehr die Ressourcen zu jeder Sitzung, ich mein,
Man sitzt da mindestens nochmal so lange, wie das ähm wie die Ausschusssitzung getagt wird, wenn das z,
um das alles zu formatieren, zu korrigieren, zu redigieren, hübsch zu machen, Zitate zu suchen und so und da geht locker mal.
Drei Tage drauf, alle zwei Wochen, äh das ist schon ordentlich.
Den ganzen Aufwand,
haben wir gemacht habe ich meinen Faden verloren.
Halt irgendwie der also die Leistung muss ja auch irgendwie gebracht werden, oder? Also ich ähm das ist jetzt schon echt ein enormer Aufwand, der ja auch finanziert werden musste.
Ja, das ist ja das Geld ist ja sowieso immer ein Problem,
mit dabei, Netzpolitik Ork ja relativ cool sind, dass wir eben nicht auf äh,
Werbung oder irgendwie unsere Seele verkaufen angewiesen sind, sondern dass wir halt den Luxus haben so ziemlich komple,
finanziert von unseren Lesern zu sein. Äh,
das äh freut mich immer wieder, wie geil das ist äh eben von der Community tatsächlich getragen zu werden,
Stationsforce für Kooperationsmodelle und was ist da draußen alles an komischen Geschäftsmodellen gibt oder Tracking,
machen zu müssen, aber ähm das hat auch irgendwie bei dem Podcast ganz gut gefunkt nachdem die sich so ein bisschen eingependelt haben, war dann tatsächlich immer Geld da, die äh Bundestagskantine äh auch für uns mit zu bezahlen und so und
Weihnachten auch Weihnachtsfeier, mal ein paar Biers getrunken auf das Internet
Das war schon cool, aber reich werden wir eh nicht bei dem Job,
des Geldes machen wir ja die ganze Aufgabe nicht, sondern weil wir das für wichtig halten.
Aber es zeigt ja zumindest eine gewisse Solidarisierung und eine Bereitschaft bei Leuten, dass ähm dass das sozusagen jetzt auch nicht nicht äh einfach nur verpufft, sondern irgendwo auch hängen bleibt. Was hat Geier.
Wir haben das ja auch unter anderem gemacht, weil sich halt nicht jeder den Luxus leisten kann in einem Donnerstag
ein ganzen Tag da drin zu sitzen. Normale Leute gehen arbeiten, ich hatte halt das Glück, dass ich das Arbeit nennen konnte, äh aber und das dazu, wenn man nicht aus Berlin kommt, ne, irgendwie
aus ganz Deutschland, aus der Schweiz, jetzt mal angereist, äh, bei den letzten Sitzungen. Das war echt so Nürdurlaub, schon ziemlich,
dafür erstmal äh in den Flieger zu steigen, um sich den Ausschuss anzuhören. Wir konnten das halt alles live
mit annehmen und so ein bisschen mehr äh Transparenz nach außen schaffen, als das,
was die anderen Medien dann dann eben so zusammengefasst haben. Ach ja genau da wollte ich von drauf raus. Am Anfang haben wir noch,
Zusätzlich zu dem relegierenden Protokollieren äh noch eine Zusammenfassung gemacht, was sind die wichtigsten Aussagen waren und das hat nochmal einen Tag gedauert und irgendwann,
man ist einfach aufgegeben, wir hatten einfach die Ressourcen nicht mehr und haben dann,
die Zusammenfassung auf Bundestag DE äh verlinkt, weil die oft ziemlich gut,
waren, die haben echt so die Essenz von dem, was neu war äh rausgeschrieben.
Ich fand's schade, dass ihr das nicht mehr gemacht habt irgendwann, aber.
Auch, aber es hat einfach keine Zeit mehr und neben dem Ausschuss haben wir auch noch ein paar andere Themen zu bearbeiten. Die Welt dreht sich ja auch noch weiter.
Ähm aber
es war schon auch so ein Novum, dass dass es das gibt. Ich meine, ich freue mich, wenn es jetzt irgendwie Leute gibt, die das nachmachen. Das sollte echt äh Schule machen,
oder nachmachen, die das auch machen, in anderen Themen, die das äh Konzept aufgreifen. Ähm wie eben dieser,
NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss, Podcast ähm wie haben denn die,
Also ihr hattet ja auch so einen zu den Ausschussmitgliedern dann irgendwie auch,
eine Beziehung, ne? Also, dass du, wie du schon sagtest, dass sie euch, äh, dass ihr da bestimmte Sonderrechte hattet irgendwie, dass ihr Brot essen durftet oder und und ähm aus der Kantine mal ein Käffchen holen oder so. Ähm,
Das war doch sicherlich für die Politiker dort auch eigentlich ein Novum eine derartiges Interesse. Ich sage jetzt mal zumindest für den Podcast von,
nicht klassischen Journalisten dort zu haben. So, dass man also du bist halt Journalist
Da werden sie vielleicht irgendwann gesagt haben, ja das ist so ein Blogger, der macht einen Live-Blog oder sowas, aber irgendwann wird ihn auch, wird ihnen aufgefallen sein, okay, das ist einfach nur ein ambitionierter Journalist, aber so diese,
klicke damit die da mit Buntstiften anreist und knete und so. Das war doch sicherlich auch ähm
ein eine Besonderheit für die für den Bundestagsalltag, oder?
Also habe ja vorhin schon mal gesagt, dass das allgemein in Untersuchungsausschuss so eine Besonderheit für einen äh Bundestagsalltag ist, also,
Ich könnte mich jetzt zum Beispiel gar nicht erinnern
und welchen es in Untersuchungsausschuss in der letzten Legislaturperiode g,
den ich mich erinnern kann, war der Irak-Kriegsuntersuchungsausschuss ein Spenderfährer CDU Spendenaffäre, unsere Plutonimafäre,
gab's ja alles Mögliche. Ähm insofern ist das
Ohnehin schon äh was Besonderes und gerade, ich meine, wir sind halt oft in unserer Perspektive mit dem NSA-Thema, dass wir halt äh die hauptsächlichen Sinnen, die das machen, aber gerade bei dem Thema NSU gibt's auch extrem viele Leute, die da so dran sind, dass wir nicht immer so unmittelbar,
mitbekommen, aber tatsächlich so in der Form Live-Blog und Podcast, wie wir das jetzt,
gezogen haben, habe ich das auch noch nicht gesehen. Mit den anderen Ausschuss.
Leuten, also sind ja nicht nur Mitglieder, also mit den Abgeordneten, mit deren Mitarbeiter, mit der,
Bundesregierung, da sind ja dann stehen ja auch noch BBD, BSI und Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte, die haben ja auch alle ähm,
Abgesandte, die da drin sitzen in den Annöhrungen und dann dazu eben das Ausschusssekretariat und so. Also irgendwann war man halt auch per Du,
Auch mit dem BND-Pressesprechern und so, äh weil man saß da, fucking sechshundertdrei äh zehn Stunden zusammen bis Mitternacht ähm,
sich gefragt, was das irgendwie warum man diesen ganzen Scheiß eigentlich macht und eigentlich war ich schon.
Nach einer Schulter zu weinen.
Da verbrüdert sich auch ein Andre Meister mit dem Start.
Eigentlich habe ich sowieso erwartet, dass es irgendwann noch eine gemeinsame Abschiedsparty gibt, so irgendwie einen Klassenausflug äh von diesen ganzen üblichen Verdächtigen.
Letzten in der letzten Sitzung noch so zum Ende noch so eine Konfettikanone von oben runterschießen könn.
Doch so eine Konfettikanone. Erschießen. Ich glaube, dann doch, darf man nicht mehr rein.
Ja. Dann nimmt er hier noch äh Linus neuen Freund mit, wie heißt er noch gleich.
Ich habe keine Freunde, ich habe nur Gegner. Ne.
Na ja, der, der, der, der fragte, ja genau, Marian Wind, also was sollen wir jetzt trinken, um mehr gegen den Terrorismus tun zu können?
Was können wir noch trinken, um mehr gegen den Terrorismus zu tun.
Aber,
Aber erstens war das ein Prozess, also wie gesagt, wir hatten ja mal den Kopf hinter uns. Am Anfang war das echt so, gucken, wie weit kann man gehen, auch ist das mit dem Live-Blog überhaupt möglich? Also wie gesagt, es gab Debatten in den Obleute-Runden
man uns das nicht verbieten sollte, aber irgendwann hat sich das so eingependelt und jetzt in der letzten Sitzung bei Merkel, da war irgendwie eine Traube von hundert Journalisten vor dem
Saal, die alle rein wollten und es gab immer nur acht fünfundachtzig Plätze,
dann haben wir schon mal wie, ich musste mich anmelden, das habe ich nicht gewusst, aber ich bin ganz wichtig, weil ich bin von ARD und wir so äh hallo und die so ja hier die üblichen Verletz
die Blogger erstmal auf eure Stammplätze. Äh, das war schon ganz net,
nur hilft halt all dieses Gemänschel nichts,
In Christian Fliesig öffentlich betont, wie sehr er jetzt aufgeklärt hat, dann aber das alles legalisiert und dann zu feige ist, den Snowden einzuladen,
Also da müssen wir echt noch bei den Themen bleiben, statt nur bei den Personen.
Also es ging mir äh also äh mir geht's einfach nur so ein bisschen darum, auch diese, diesen Weg nachzuzeichnen und an, also,
zu ermutigen dieses dieses Konzept weiter zu tragen in andere Ausschüsse, ne? Dass man da irgendwie
irgendwann auch ein halbwegs
akzeptabelen Umgang findet. Ich fand das irgendwie noch sehr amüsant. Ich habe immer in meinem Rucksack ein ein Aufzeichnen geredet, also ein Aufnahmegerät für äh wenn ich mal unterwegs was aufzeichne, hauptsächlich nutze ich das für.
Wie Radio kurz, äh können sie mal eben, dann halte ich das eben an Wunschsprecher rein und schicke denen die Datei oder so. Äh
Es gibt halt einerseits diese Kontrolle am Eingang, wo dieser, in welchen Ausschuss wollen sie, ne? Und dann kommt halt nachher diese Sicherheit,
haben sie Mikrofone im Rucksack, ja, ja, ja, okay, nee, dann ist in Ordnung.
Die müssen in irgendein besonderes Bild machen, habe ich auch öfter am Flughafen,
und ich bin da immer mit mit Aufzeichnung Geräte reingegangen. Ich habe aber nichts aufgenommen.
Du darfst das ja mitnehmen, du darfst dich anders benutzen. Man hört's ja auch, das Smartphone ist Augenaufnahmegerät.
Wir verraten unsere Tricks nicht. Gut. Andre, vielen vielen Dank.
Genau, vielen Dank.
Für drei Jahre Selbstgeißelung.
Und die tausend Seiten lesen, die ihr in der Spiel lesen wollt.
Ja, das musste jetzt noch bringen.
Machen wir dann gemeinsam hier im Podcast oder machen wir eine Les.
Machen wir eine Lesung und äh können mal, ey, kann man echt vielleicht machen, ne? Wir überlegen mal. Ähm.
Er schafft es auch mit den Stunden auf unsere Ausschusssitzungen zu kommen.
Nee, vielen, vielen Dank für dein und anders Engagement,
technische Aufklärung haben wir hier regelmäßig gelobt.
Wetter hat auch ein Protokoll gemacht und Thomas Rudel hat auch zwei gemacht.
Wichtig, dass auch äh da auch drauf hinzuweisen, ähm für die ganze Aufarbeitung und so nochmal ähm herzlichen Dank an alle.
Genau, dem kann ich mich nur anschließen. Dann haben wir's, oder?
Damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Der Sendung. Andre, Ninos. Wir sagen alles tschüs.
Ciao ciao.
Und zündlone Konfettikanone.
Genau peng.